welcome to this complete Elixir course
this course created by octolium covers
the fundamentals of Elixir and
functional programming including
recursion pattern matching and the actor
model the course also covers data types
flow control and advanced topics such as
mixed projects and list operations by
the end of this course you'll be able to
build your own Elixir applications and
confidently apply functional programming
Concepts in your projects hi and welcome
to this course functional programming
with Elixir now this course is all about
learning the fundamentals of functional
programming and we are going to learn
these Fundamentals by using the Elixir
programming language now this course is
for someone who has some basic knowledge
of programming but you don't need to be
an expert maybe you know a little bit of
JavaScript python Java or C plus plus it
doesn't matter but you do need to have
some kind of programming experience now
let us go through all of the topics that
we would be covering inside this
tutorial Series so the first thing as
you can see that we are going to learn
all of the basic fundamentals of
functional programming and after that we
are also going to learn all of the
basics of Elixir you can see that we are
going to cover all of the type system of
Elixir as well then we will see how to
create projects by using mix so this is
the basic tutorial project that we are
going to create and as a last Capstone
project we are going to create an actual
statistics Library well that's it for
this video I hope you are excited to
learn more about functional programming
and elixir in general and I'll catch you
in the next video
so what exactly is elixir now Alexa is a
functional programming language
now why am I talking about elixir
well let me answer this by asking you a
question
when was the last time you used WhatsApp
or Discord
well both of these applications there
are on the same virtual machine
now to be precise Discord is powered by
Elixir and WhatsApp is powered by erlang
you must be thinking what erlang has to
do with Elixir well erlang is also a
functional programming language and
Alexa is built on the top of erlang and
both of these languages they are
compiled and they run on the airline
virtual machine which is also called as
the beam
you can imagine this to be similar to
your Java virtual machine
you have so many languages such as Java
kotlin closure and Scala all of these
languages they compile and they run on
the on the Java virtual machine the same
thing happens with Elixir Elixir gets
compiled and Resident on the beam
virtual machine
now you must be thinking why is all of
these things important what's so great
about about elixir well first it is
functional second it supports
immutability by default
now why is immutability so very
important well because of that we can
have immense scalability You Must Be
Wondering Why because since all of the
data types is immutable that means there
is no chances for the threads or some
other objects or maybe some other
functions to accurately change the
values so the state is preserved and
that's why the systems becomes much more
scalable
and the most powerful thing about Elixir
is that it supports fault tolerance
suppose NFL node goes down or any of our
actors or processors goes down then
automatically they can be revived and
they can be revived with its own state
so that's why you can create immensely
distributed and fault all done systems
by using elixir
so if you're interested in learning
Elixir then stay tuned and I will meet
you in the next video bye so now we know
a little bit more about Elixir but let
us try and understand what do we mean by
functional programming in simple terms
it simply means that our entire program
is composed of different functions
so just imagine that this f of x is a
kind of a function so let me highlight
the background so this the green thing
so this is a very simple function now
this function it gets an input suppose
that input is an X now this function is
going to transform that data from X and
that data would be transformed to
something called as y
so this is what your function is going
to do your function will always accept
some kind of an argument it will
transform the data and it will always
give you back some kind of data now this
may look very simple but it's not so
simple there are a lot of things that go
behind creating your pure functions so
let us try and understand what makes
functional programming so unique the
first thing is obviously we don't have
any classes or objects inside functional
programming
the next one is all of the data type is
immutable so it's just like working with
constants throughout your program now
you must be wondering why do we need
immutable data types or constants
the answer is since the data is not
mutable that means the state Remains the
Same and if the state Remains the Same
that means that data can be copied and
it can be distributed much more easily
and since this data can be distributed
that means we can create immensely
scalable systems by using function
programming now this brings me to the
next point and I think that this point
is going to shock a couple of us and
that means we don't have any for loops
now since the data is immutable that's
why we don't have for loops just try and
imagine your typical for Loop suppose
you have your variable of I equal to 0 I
Which is less than length and I plus
plus now what's happening is for each
iteration your variable of I is
increasing that means the data is
constantly mutating but we can't have
that because we have immutable data
types you must be thinking then what's
the point how can we have iterations in
Elixir but functional programming and
elixir has a much better way of doing
loops and that is by using recursion
and I am going to talk more about
recursion right in the next video so
what do you mean by recursion and why is
recursion so important
let us try to answer these questions one
by one
first let us see what do you mean by
recursion in simple terms whenever you
perform the same task again and again
you can say that you are performing a
recursion that means you can see that we
have one task and this task is calling
itself again and again so you can say
that we are in a state of recursion now
if recursion is so simple then what's
the big deal with recursion let me try
and explain this by taking you through a
journey in time
you must have heard about the seven
wonders of the world you have the Taj
Mahal you have the Great Wall of China
you have the Machu Picchu and so on but
if we ask each one of us what do you
consider as the wonder of the world
the answer is going to vary let us see
what's going to happen next so these are
some of the most smartest guys on the
planet so they are Warren Buffett and
the great Charlie manga if you ask these
guys what do you think is one of the
wonders of the world then most possibly
the answer would be compounding now let
us see what's going to happen next so
there is one more really smart guy and
as you can imagine this is the great
Isaac Newton if you ask Newton what
would be one of the greatest wonders of
the world
most probably he is going to say that
it's gravity so the point that I am
trying to make is our perception changes
from person to person
now what happens if you ask this guy
that's me
photo I think about one of the greatest
wonders of the world and as you can
guess my answer would be recursion well
that's not exactly true if you want a
very honest answer from me then I think
that recursion plus mutation that means
recursive mutation is one of the
greatest wonders of this world
sounds confusing is it don't worry now
it's time for some explanation
just consider us human beings all of us
have habits right and we tend to have
the same habits over a long period of
time so can we say that our mind is in a
state of recursion because we keep on
repeating the same habit each and every
day you may argue that our habits can
also change
well yes they can change and that's what
I mean by mutation but just try and
consider your habits don't change
drastically overnight
your habits may change over a long
period of time so you can also say that
your change in habit is because of small
mutations that take place each and every
day
so maybe you can say that all of us are
in a state of recursive mutation
let's try and go a little larger let us
try and think about the Earth itself
now the Earth takes around 24 hours to
come to the exact same point
so can you say that Earth is also in a
state of recursion let us try and expand
a little bit further now the Earth
revolves around the Sun in an orbit now
this as you know it takes around 12
months time
but what happens in every four years we
have a leap year that means we have a
day extra
so can you say that even the Earth is in
the state of recursive mutation now let
us try and go even behind our solar
system
you must have also heard that the entire
universe is in the state of expansion
this go back 13.6 billion years ago when
there was nothing the Big Bang happened
and the Earth Stars sun and entire
galaxies came into existence and we are
still expanding how can this happen well
I can explain this by using a function
which is written recursively
so this is our function for now you
don't have to understand all of these
things you will understand these things
in the future when you learn a little
bit more about Elixir right now let us
try and see how the universe can expand
from nothing
so if I say universe and now this is the
time for the Big Bang
and big bank is a function which takes
no argument
now let us see what's going to happen
Okay so the Big Bang happened
after that you can see that the size of
universe is 0 1 2 3 4 and the size is
constantly expanding
now let me stop this otherwise this will
go for Infinity so what exactly happened
you can see that I have a function
called as expand and at the last the
function is calling itself again but
this time we are just mutating the state
I have written State plus 1 but imagine
that this is not plus one we are causing
some kind of mutation and that is what
this is supposed to symbolize
now this brings me to the last point
so as you can imagine the very nature of
the universe is recursive that means all
of the mathematics that we study for
programming that 2 is recursive in
nature
and this concept of recursion comes
naturally to functional programming
so now we get it we had to take a really
long journey in order to understand what
is the recursion and what's the big deal
with it now let's see how to install
elixir
so what you can do is you can just go to
this website which is elixirlang.org and
you can simply click on install
and if you're using Windows you can
click on windows so from here you can
download the installer and as the
instruction already says you have to
Simply click on next next and finally
finish and if you are on a Mac you can
simply use Brew to install elixir
so if you are on a Mac you can open up a
terminal and you can type Brew install
an elixir
and once you have installed Elixir what
I want you to do is uh just open up a
terminal or if you are using Windows
just open up the Powershell and here you
can simply type Elixir and hyphen V so
as you can see I'm currently running
Elixir
1.14.1 and if you are watching this
video in the future you may have some
other version but don't worry all of the
things which I teach you right now they
are going to work in future versions as
well the next thing for this video is
let us open up our Visual Studio code
and let us set up the Elixir plugin for
this one so just open up your extensions
and I want you to just search for elixir
so this extension which is for Elixir LS
so here you can see and currently it has
like 339 000 downloads so just install
this plugin and this is what you really
need to start working with Elixir inside
vs code the first time you open up any
Elixir file inside vs code you will get
a small pop-up right over here somewhere
in the bottom right corner and that
pop-up will be saying that Alexa is
building the PLT so just let it happen
it's going to take some time but let it
run and after the Alexa PLT is built you
can start working with your Elixir files
inside vs code
now that we have Alexa installed it's
time to start learning more about elixir
but first before learning we need to
start unlearning because a lot of
Concepts from the object oriented world
does not exist in the functional world
so that brings me to the very first
statement if I say a is equal to 1 and
if I ask you what do you think of it
most probably you will say that a is a
variable and the value of 1 is being
assigned to the variable of a well you
are right
but that's not what is happening inside
the functional world
if I take you back to your high school
days and just imagine that you are
taking your very basic algebra classes
in that class what we learned was
a is equal to 1 that means a is your
left hand side and one is your right
hand side
so what maths is trying to say is your
left hand side is equal to your right
hand side
your basic algebra does not say that one
is being assigned to a that concept does
not exist
now if we say that if the left hand side
is equal to the right hand side that
means the right hand side should also be
equal to the left hand side
so if I say that a is equal to 1 that
means even this statement should hold
true and that is what happens in the
world of Elixir as well
we will also have a demo of this shortly
right now just keep in mind that equal
to is not the assignment operator this
is the match operator and what this
operator does is that it simply matches
your right hand side to your left hand
side and you are going to see this
pattern a lot inside Elixir this is also
called as pattern matching and this is a
very powerful thing inside elixir
every time you see a statement like this
always remember that we are simply
trying to match the right hand side with
the left hand side
now for the demo let us open up our
terminal
Elixir actually ships with an
interactive shell or an repel so let us
see how we can open it up and start
using elixir we can enter inside the
intra to Shell by typing IEX
you can clear the terminal by typing
clear
so here we can say that my a is equal to
1. now if we say that is my 1 is equal
to my a and we get the output as true
you can also type as 1 is equal to a and
this simply gives back the value because
1 and a both hold the same value of 1.
let me clear this up let us try with one
more experiment suppose I say that my
name is
octallium
so in this case if I say that is
equal to my name
then we should get the answer of true
and yes that's what it is so just keep
in mind that this is equal to is not
assignment we are simply trying to
pattern match the right hand side to the
left hand side let's try to learn a
little bit more about pattern matching
and let us have a look at this example
now the square brackets means that this
is a list and I will be covering more
about list a little later in the series
but for now let us just go with the flow
for now I don't want you to concentrate
on the syntax I want you to concentrate
just on the right hand side and the left
hand side
can you see that the pattern on the
right is the same as the pattern on the
left we have two variables on the left
hand side we have two values on the
right hand side here you can say that
the value of 1 is now bound to the
variable of a
now the next variable is also a and the
value inside a is also 1 and that's what
it is
so this is going to be true inside
elixir
for a quick demo let me open up my
terminal and I'm already inside IEX in
case if you are for Photon how to go
inside IEX let me show you once again
for quitting IEX just press Ctrl C twice
and you can put the IEX and again if you
want to go inside just type as i e and X
again let me clear it up
so here I can say that my list has two
variables a and a and
the values are 1 and 1.
so here it is it's a perfect match the
right hand side is equal to the left
hand side so we get the values back
if I just say I want to see the value of
a
and here it is we get the value of a as
1. now let us go back
now can you guess what is going to
happen this time
now this time you can see that we have
the values of a and a and on the right
we have the value of 1 and 2. well let
us go to our IEX and see what's going to
happen this time
so we have this A and A and on the right
we have 1 and 2. let us see what's going
to happen
o we get an error and if you watch
closely we get an error saying that no
match of the right hand side
and yes it is not a match the reason is
the value of 1 is bound to the variable
of a
and again the second value is a but this
time the value inside a is 1 and on the
right the value is 2 so 2 is not equal
to 1 and that's why the right hand side
and the left hand side are not a match
and that's why we get an error let us go
back
now what happens if we write something
like this if we switch the second value
from a to a new variable of B
can you guess what is going to happen
well let us go back and let us see
what's going to happen this time
so here let me change the value from A
to B
and let us see well yes it's a perfect
match
so what's happening this time the value
of 1 is bound to the variable of a and
the value of 2 is bound to the variable
of B
we can check it out so if I say a then
we get the value of 1 and if I say B we
get the value of 2 and that is what it
is right over here
always try and think in terms of pattern
matching that means we always want to
have the right hand side equal to our
left hand side
so this is also called as pattern
matching and as I have said earlier this
is a very powerful pattern inside Elixir
and we would be using this pattern
matching throughout this entire tutorial
series
till now we have seen a little bit about
pattern matching inside elixir
and we have been using our terminal but
we can do a much better job
and allow me to introduce to you
livebook so livebook is actually like
the Jupiter notebooks for Elixir but
before I can show you live book you must
have noticed that I have a different
prompt and I have a couple of more
colors inside my terminal and this is
because I'm using a little bit more
fancier setup but that's about it now
let me go to livebook
so here it is you can simply navigate to
this website livebook.dev and from here
we can simply install livebook on our
machine so just click on install
and from here you can choose your Mac or
Windows and download the setup and after
you have downloaded the setup just
install it as you would install any
other program in your machine now I have
already installed live book so let me
just open it up here it is
so this is how it is
we can start a new notebook we can
simply click over here new notebook and
that's it we are good to go let us try
the same code that we wrote inside our
terminal so here I can see is my a comma
a equal to my 1 comma 1 and simply you
can click over here evaluate
and now we have the output right over
here let us try with some other examples
so here I can say
if my a is equal to 1 then is my
1 equal to a and let us try to evaluate
in this cell and yes we get the output
now what I have done just for a
reference I have also included a couple
of notebooks and you can find all of
those right over here so this is the
GitHub repo for this entire tutorial
series which is octallium slash oops uh
it's right over here
you can go to octallium and slash
functional programming with Elixir and
inside notebooks you can see that I have
a couple of notebooks now in the future
I may add a couple of more notebooks to
this one but at the time of recording we
have three of those
so let us see how we can open this
notebooks inside our live book so let me
go back to my live book
and let me just click on this icon on
the left
and here I simply have to choose my path
so I have to go inside my GitHub
octalium functional programming with
Elixir notebooks and let me choose the
first one and let me simply click on
open so this is the first live book that
you can find inside the repository and
as you can see I have included a couple
of text and also a couple of code blocks
for your reference
so this is what we were trying to do
last time
and if you see right over here I have
created some more examples so if my name
is is equal to octallium then my
octalium should also be equal to name
and so on so what you can do maybe you
can try to create a couple of more
notebooks and you can try to open up the
notebooks which I have included inside
the repo and I'll catch you in the next
video
till now we have been trying to learn
more about pattern matching and let us
continue with the same thing in this
video as well
now let us go back to our terminal and
let me coincide IEX
so I can do that by simply typing IEX
now again please let me remind you that
my prompt is looking different and that
is because I have customized the
settings I just wanted to have the
prompt to be same as my logo that's why
I simply changed it but that's about it
now let me clear up the terminal and
here let us try to learn a little bit
more about pattern matching so again let
us create the same list a and a and for
the right hand side let us say that we
want to match with 1 and 2 and as you
know we are going to get a match error
and this is what we are getting
so again let me try and refresh a memory
what's happening so what's happening is
the value or the variable of a is bound
to the value of 1. and on the next time
what's happening is here we have a but
we are trying to match the value of 2
with a and as you know a is bound to 1
that's why we are getting match error
now let's take a couple of minutes and
let us try to understand why this is
happening this is happening because all
of the data types inside Elixir are
immutable that means we can't randomly
assign new values to an existing
variable inside Elixir now you must be
thinking that why does all of the types
inside Elixir has to be immutable the
short answer is because for scalability
and we will come to this point in the
next video but for now let us try to
understand what's happening behind the
scenes now let me try to clear up the
screen one more time and this time let
us say that we want our a and we want on
the right to be 1. so this time what's
happening is we have a match operator
right over here and the value of 1 is
bound to the variable of a but here
comes a small caveat so if I say a is
equal to 2 so this time we do not have
an error but I just said that our data
types are immutable inside Elixir so
what's happening so whenever we have a
variable on the left hand side of our
match operator at that time Alexa thinks
that we want to bound the new value to
the variable on the left that's why we
have the new value instead of a which is
true but if you don't want this Behavior
then we can use a pin operator so we can
say the pin operator and a is equal to 3
so this time as you can see we get a
match error and the match error is
saying that no match of right hand side
value of 3 and this is because instead
of a we have the value of 2 and on the
left hand side we are trying to match a
value of 3 that's why we get the match
error now if we try to do this thing the
other way around and if we say that 3 is
equal to a so again this time we get an
error saying that no match and the right
hand side value is 2 so yes as you can
see right over here the value which is
bound to a is 2 and that's why 3 is not
equal to 2 and we get a match error and
on line number 4 we could rebound the
new value of 2 to our variable of a just
because this variable is on the left
hand side of the match operator for now
you don't have to worry too much about
these things as we progress and as we
saw a couple of more examples all of
these things will get cleared very
easily now coming to the next Point why
do we need immutability inside Elixir
and my short answer was scalability so
let me try to explain why immutability
helps in scalability
since our data is not immutable that
means the data can be easily copied
across various processes and we don't
have to worry if another resource
another thread or another process is
changing or trying to mutate our data
this thing will get clear when we
understand how code is executed inside
Elixir and when we understand the actor
model and that's what we are going to do
right in the next video let us try to
understand how all of the code inside
Elixir gets executed now all of the code
gets executed in something which is
called as an actor
so you can imagine your actor to be
something like this box now this is an
isolated box and what happens is this
box or this actor receives some kind of
messages now this messages could be data
it could be instructions of what to do
with the data and so on
after receiving these messages your
actor is going to process your messages
and it is simply going to give you back
some kind of a response so in simple
terms you can imagine actor to be like
an isolated competition unit it gets
something it processes something and it
gives back something now what happens is
this act as they run inside something
which is called as processes and at a
given time we can have millions and
millions of processes
this is where the data immutability
comes into picture we can have millions
of copies of our data and they can be
distributed across various actors not
only on our local machine but we can
have a global cluster of different
servers and we can distribute our load
horizontally across the globe
so these processes are not your
operating system processes you can
imagine them to be like your virtual
threads so let's try to understand these
processes one step at a time we just saw
the actor model and this actors they run
inside your processes
for each process we have a separate ID
which is called as bid and I will show
you the bid shortly in this video
the next part is we can communicate
between these processes by message
passing
and as we just said that since our data
is immutable we can create multiple
copies and this copies can be assigned
to different processors
and since each actor gets its own copy
of data we don't have to worry if
another is changing the state everything
runs in isolation
the next part is each process has its
own stack and Heap allocation so if we
come from a compiled programming
language such as C or C plus plus
we have different memory allocation
models you can allocate your memory
inside the stack or on the Heap
and in case of Elixir each process gets
its own stack and hip allocation so this
way the garbage collection is very fast
we have to just garbage collect for a
single process and our application
remains responsive at the same time next
let us have a little bit more details
about our actors every actor has its own
mailbox so every message that you pass
to an independent process they are
collected inside this mailbox and after
that they are executed in a sequential
order and the Order of execution is
first in and first out
next this processes are very cheap to
create they require less than 3 KB of
memory so you can see it's very cheap
and we can spawn millions of processors
at a given time and the last part to
remember is we always communicate with
message passing now let us go back to
our terminal and let us check our bid
over there so pit stands for your
process ID
so the first thing is let us go inside
our IEX let me clear up everything now
this IEX is also running inside a
separate process and we can check the
process ID by using the built-in
function called as self now the next
thing about Elixir is the parentheses
are not mandatory self is a function you
can write the parentheses or you can
leave them out but these days the
general convention is whenever you are
writing code inside the code editor at
that time we prefer parentheses but on
the terminal it's all up to you I am
going to leave them out
and here we get the output so the
current process ID in which our IEX is
running is right over here and this is
the address
0.107.0 so that's it for this one and I
will catch you in the next video
I think now we know enough of Elixir and
now it's time to write the all important
hello world program so let us get
started let me open up my terminal and
here let me create a folder by the name
of functional programming with Elixir
now let me go inside of this folder
and here let me create one more
directory for Scripts
let me go inside my scripts directory
and here let me create one more file by
the name of Hello dot EXs now Elixir has
two file extensions this dot s that you
can see right over here this means that
we want to create a script file and
whenever we want to create a compile
file that time we simply write as dot EX
we will see more about the dot ex
extension when we create our first
project by using the mix tool but right
now just keep in mind that whenever we
want to create a script at that time we
simply add a s now there are a lot of
times when you need extra files for
example you need a file to just seed
your database
or if you want a file just for testing
these files are not meant to go into
production they are just meant for your
development now let me go ahead and
create this file and let us open up this
file inside our code editor
now my code editor is complaining that
no mix file found so right now just
ignore this and when we create a project
by using mix it will go away let me
collapse my sidebar so the first thing
that you should keep in mind that all of
the code inside Elixir stays inside its
modules so let's create a module and for
creating module we simply have to say
that we want to define a module and let
us name the model as hello and next for
Elixir we don't have curly brackets
instead we have the do and end blocks so
what we have done till now is we have
simply defined a module and all of the
code will go inside this module as a
general convention the module name and
the file name should be same it's not
required but just as in community
convention they should be equal for
example let me open up my sidebar here
you can see that we have named the file
as hello and we have also named the
module as hello let me collapse my
sidebar and inside of this module let us
create our first function and you can
create functions by using the keyword
cordless Dev and let us call our
function as world now this function will
not accept anything so you can't keep
your blank parentheses or you can leave
them out completely that means this is a
function which does not accept any
parameter then again we need to create
our do and end blocks and here we can
say that from our input output we simply
want to put something to our output and
here we simply want to display the
message of hello Elixir now always use
the double quotes for defining your
strings single codes are meant for
characters but right now since we want a
string that's why we have put double
quotes now let us save this program and
let us see how we can run this program
let me adjust the screen we can run this
file in a couple of different ways so
let us see the first method here we can
simply say that hey Elixir I simply want
you to run the file which is called as
hello.exs
and you can see that Elixir actually ran
our file but we don't have any output
and we don't have an output because we
have not called the function of word so
let us do that right over here let me
take my terminal slightly down and here
what we can do is here we can say that
from our model of hello I want to call
the function of world let us save the
file and now let us go to our terminal
and let us try to run the same command
one more time and this time we get the
output of hello elixir so you can use
this method whenever we want to run a
script file but Elixir is actually a
compiled language so let us see how we
can actually compile this file now again
please keep this in mind that whenever
we want to have a compiled file that
time the file extension should be dot ex
but right now let me show you how we can
compile and run this script so let me
clear up my terminal and here instead of
writing Elixir we can say that Elixir
compiler by adding a c right over here
so this stands for Elixir compiler so
now Elixir is actually going to compile
this file and then it will run for us so
let me open up the sidebar here you can
see that we have a single file hello.exs
and this one is created by our virtual
Studio code now let us compile the file
and let us see what happens
so as you can see in the sidebar Elixir
actually compiled and we have a new file
called as
elixir.hello.beam now remember that
Elixir runs on the beam virtual machine
and this is the compiled file for our
Elixir code but normally we don't
compile and run the Elixir files like
this we would use the mix tool and we
will learn more about the mix tool as we
progress in the tutorials but right now
let us go with the flow now let me
collapse my sidebar we can also run this
file inside our interactive shell so let
me show you how we can do that let us go
inside our interact with shell and let
me clear up everything now here we can
say that we want to compile the file of
hello.exs
and that's it now we are getting a
warning saying that redefining module
hello and that's because just a couple
of seconds back we actually compiled
this file and that file is currently
inside our memory but right now we can
simply ignore all of these things next
your IEX actually ran the file and here
we can see we have the output of hello
Elixir now let me clear up the screen
one more time and let us see how we can
also manually call the function
so here we can say that I want you to go
to the model of hello and from there I
want you to go to the function of word
now remember that parentheses are
optional inside Elixir and since our
function of world does not accept any
parameters I can have my blank
parentheses or I can simply leave them
out
and here you can see that we have an
output of hello Elixir and after this we
also have a message saying as okay now
okay symbolizes a data type which is
called as atom
we will learn more about the data types
in the next video but right now let us
go with the flow now again let me close
my terminal and this time let us make
the function accept some kind of a
parameter so here we can say that we
want the function of world to accept a
parameter and we want to name the
parameter as name next we can use our
string interpolation so here let me take
out Elixir and here we need to put the
hash sign and then we need to put the
curly brackets and inside the curly
brackets I can simply use our parameter
of name and also let me take out this
line This is not required so let us open
up our terminal and we have our IEX
running now since we changed the file
let us recompile the module and we can
do that by typing R now R stands for
recompile and we simply want to
recompile our model of hello and that's
it we have redefined the module let me
clear it up and here we can say that
hello Dot world and now let us pass a
parameter called as octallium and we
have the output of hello octalium now
remember that the parentheses are
optional so we can also write something
like this let me take out the
parentheses and let me give a space
right between over here so as we can see
this code is also valid and we get the
exact same output well that's it for
this video and we will see the different
data types in Elixir right from the next
one let us try to learn more about the
different data types in elixir the first
thing which I wanted to remind you is
all of the data types in Elixir are
immutable in common terms what I mean to
say is all of the data types inside
Elixir are constants
now with this concept in mind let us go
ahead and let us try to study the first
data type and the data type is called as
an atom an atom in Elixir looks
something like this so we have a colon
symbol right over here and after the
colon we have the name of the atom and
in case there is some space inside the
name of the atom then we can write an
atom like this so again the syntax goes
like this your item will always start
with a colon and then we have the name
of the item and in this case since we
have a space inside the name of our item
we are using double quotes and inside
the double quotes we have the name of
the atom now this was just the syntax of
an atom but now let us go ahead and let
us try to understand what's an item all
about so let's consider this scenario so
we have a symbol or a logo like this can
you tell me what this logo symbolizes
now this logo is of a very popular brand
Android brand is Nike so what's
happening in this case this symbol is
synonymous with the name of Nike if I
show you the symbol or if I show you the
name both of this values point to the
exact same thing so this is just a
pseudo code and this is not a valid
Elixir syntax but let us understand the
concept of an atom so what's happening
right over here is we have a variable
and the name of the variable is Nike and
the value assigned to this variable is
also Nike so in short the value and the
name are the same and this is what an
item represents in an atom the name and
the value is always same and we can
represent this in terms of atom like
this so we have an atom for Nike let us
open up our IEX and we can start playing
right over there so this is my terminal
let me go inside my IEX and let me clear
up the screen so let us create the same
item for Nike so you can say Nike this
is what an atom is all about suppose we
had a very long name that had spaces in
between so we can say something like
this the and Nike
so this is also a valid atom and you
will notice that our atom always starts
with a colon now what we can do is let
us go to our live book and then we can
create a couple of more examples of atom
so this is our live book and let us
create a new notebook
let me give the title as data types and
this section is all about our atom in
Elixir you will see atoms everywhere
atoms are very heavily used for pattern
matching now suppose you are working on
some kind of an application and you want
to return an error message so that time
what we can do is we can simply create
an atom called as error so we can say
something like this error and let us
click on evaluate so here it is we have
created an item which is called as error
next let me show you a very practical
use of this kind of an atom so let's
take the exact same example suppose we
are working on an application and we
have an error where we are not able to
find a file so at that time it's very
common to return back a tuple and the
Tuple is represented by this early
strings now I will cover tuples a little
later in the series but right now let's
go with the flow and inside the Tuple we
can say that the first element is an
error so there is some error in that
operation and then we can describe the
reason for the error so we can say for
example file not found and this kind of
pattern is very common inside Elixir
normally we will have a two element
Tuple or a three element apple and
regularly you will see that we simply
pattern match on this Tuple so what we
can do is on the left hand side we can
again pattern match with this Tuple so
let me create a new Tuple right over
here and the first element is an error
the second element we can call it as a
reason now again what's happening over
here is we are simply using our pattern
matching I want you to go back to the
concept of your left hand side is equal
to your right hand side so on the right
hand side we have a tuple and on the
left hand side we have a tuple next what
is happening is on the right we have a
string called as file not found and on
the left we have a variable oh let let
me get the spelling right this has to be
reason so what's happening is since we
have a variable on the left hand side
this value of file not found is being
bound to our variable of reason so let
us click on re-evaluate and let us see
what's happening and we get our Tuple
back error file not found let us split
this into different code blocks so let
me create a code block right over here
and let me take this code or from here
and let me paste it right over here
again let me click on the evaluate and
here also we can evaluate now what we
can do is since we are using pattern
matching we can extract the value of
file not found and I just said that this
value of file not found is bound to our
variable of reason and we can check out
the value by simply typing our reason
and let us click on re-evaluate and here
we get the value back file not found now
this pattern is very very common in
elixir
so let us have a look at one more
example and suppose this time we have a
successful operation uh for example if
we are working on some kind of an web
application and we get back a status 200
message so at that time what we can do
is we can pattern match on OK and then
we can have a message and here we can
pass our OK and we can say status 200
okay and then we can see the contents of
our message now let us click on evaluate
and as you can see we get the value of
message back so again the same thing is
happening over here we simply have to
Pat and match the right hand side along
with the left hand side OK is matching
with the OK right over here and this
string is being bound to our variable of
message and that's what we are calling
on the next line right over here well
this was all about atoms and in the next
video we'll start with strings inside
elixir
the next data type in our series is
going to be the string and strings in
Elixir are represented by double quotes
So this is going to be a valid string
for Elixir we have the double quotes and
inside the double quotes we have the
string now instead of the double quotes
if you use a single code then that would
mean a character list and a character
list is different from a string inside
Elixir now let us go and play a little
bit with strings inside our IEX
now let us go inside our IEX
and let me clear up the screen and as I
just said we can create a string by
using our double quotes so let me write
octalium so this is going to be a valid
string inside Elixir now what happens
the IEX also provides us with a lot of
convenience functions for checking
different data types and one such
function for displaying the information
is called as I so let us call I and let
us pass the variable of octallium and
let us see what kind of output we are
getting
so we can see that the term is octallium
and the data type is a binary string so
what happens inside Elixir is your
strings are actually saved as a
collection of bytes that's why it is
saying that the data type is a binary
string next the size of our string is 9
bytes and the next thing that you can
see is in Elixir a string is actually a
UTF 8 encoded binary now I just said
that your strings are saved as a
collection of bytes and this is how it
actually looks inside your memory and as
you must have noticed it starts with
double angle brackets and it also ends
with the double angle brackets now
inside of this collection you can see
that we have the individual integer
representation of each of the characters
inside our string for example the
integer of 79 denotes uh o 99 denotes a
c and so on next we can also see a
couple of protocols that are implemented
for the type of a string now Protocols
are a slightly Advanced topic and will
not be covering protocols in this
tutorial but for now let us go ahead and
let us see what else we can do with the
strings now let us have a look at a
little bit of magic of pattern matching
with our strings now strings is just a
collection of our bytes and what we can
do is we can use our pattern matching to
extract individual code points from our
string so let me clear up the screen and
here what we can do is we can simply
match for an O for octallium so we can
say that our first character should be o
and the next one we can collect in a
different variable called as rest is
equal to octallium and let us see what
happens next now let us see the contents
of the variable of rest and here we can
see that the rest variable contains all
of the alphabets after o so what's
happening on this line right over here
so again the same thing goes your left
hand side should be equal to your right
hand side on the right hand side we have
a capital O and that is being pattern
match right over here and next we have a
string concatenation operator and we are
saying that we want to collect all of
the different code points after o inside
a variable called as rest so what
happens all of the other characters
starting from C all the way to M these
characters get bound to our variable of
rest and that's what we are checking on
line number six let us have a look at
one more example suppose we again want
to see the information for a new string
called as ABC now again the parentheses
are optional so even if I take out this
parenthesis still the code should work
and here we get the output and here we
can see that the raw representation of a
band C is right over here now what's
happening is 97 simply denotes the code
point for our character of a and we can
check that out by using a different
syntax so we can put a question mark
followed by a so this gives us the code
Point representation for a and here we
can see that it's 97 and that's what we
have right over here now suppose we want
to see the code 0.4 B so B is going to
be 98 and for C is going to be 99 and so
on now with all of these points in our
mind let us go back to our live book
and let's start playing a little bit
more with our strings
so here let us create a new section so I
want to go on block and create a new
section and this section is all about
your strings
so let us create the same string right
over here so we can say we want to
create a variable called as name and let
us assign the value of octalum to this
one next let us just print out the value
of name and let us see what output we
are getting and as expected we are
getting our string back next we can also
check if the given data is of the type
of string or not
so for that we can use an inbuilt
function called as is binary so remember
your strings are represented as a
collection of your raw code points or a
collection of your bytes so we can use
this function of s binary and let us
pass the variable of name and let us try
to evaluate and we get the answer as
true so yes this is a binary that means
this is a string next let us see how we
can add two strings together
so let me create a new code block and
let us create a new variable called as
message and here we can create a message
saying that hello and for adding or for
concatenating we have to use this double
angle brackets and then let us pass our
variable of name so again just to help
you remember your we have the angle
brackets and if you go back to our
terminal and here we can see the raw
representation here also we have the
angle brackets the only difference is
for the representation we use the double
angle brackets
and for string concatenation we use the
single angle bracket so let us see the
output of this one so let us try to
evaluate and here we have the message of
hello octarian next we can use our
pattern matching and let us try to
extract values from the string so let's
create a new code block and here again
we can pattern match so we can say that
the first couple of characters should be
hello and after hello I want to collect
the remaining in a new variable called
as name and on the right hand side we
have to Simply pass the message so
remember message is hello octallium so
hello and this space right over here
this is going to be pattern matching
right over here and the name of octalum
would be bound to our variable of name
next we can also check out the contents
of the variable of name so let us write
it over here and let us try to evaluate
and here we get the name back as
octalium now there is one more way of
pattern matching with our strings
and this method is by pattern matching
on the raw representations so let's see
how we can do that so let us create a
new code block now remember that the raw
string representation is done by our
double angle brackets and here let us
try to pattern match so here we can say
that we want to pattern match the first
character or the first code point in a
new variable and let us call that
variable as head next what we want to do
is we simply want to collect all of the
remaining code points in the new
variable and we can call that variable
as rest now since we are using the raw
string representation we also need to
tell to elixir in which format do we
want to collect all of the rest code
points so here we can say that the type
of rest would be binary and on the right
hand side we simply have to pattern
match with name and next let us see what
is inside our variable of head and let
us try to evaluate this cell so what's
happening right now is instead of
getting a string back we actually get
the code point back and if we refer back
to our terminal as we can see right over
here so this 97 actually denotes our
code point of a so that's what is
happening right over here so in this
case 79 actually denotes the code point
for our o and we can check it out in a
new blog so let us create a new block
right over here and here we can say that
is my head is equal to the code point of
O and let us try to evaluate and see
what answer we are getting so yes the
answer is true so if you are feeling a
little bit confused so let us go back to
our terminal
let me clear all of these things and let
us check the code point for our
character of O and we get the integer
representation as 79 and that's what we
are checking right over here so the
value inside head is 79 and that's what
we are checking in this line and since
the character value of O is also 79
that's why this expression is evaluating
to a true so you can see that pattern
matching is very powerful inside Elixir
and we use pattern matching practically
everywhere inside elixir let us take the
same example so let me copy from here
and let's create a new code block and
let me paste it right over here and here
instead of using this variable of head
let us pattern match on o and let us see
if we can get the rest back and let us
try to evaluate this expression and we
get the right answer back so we get all
of the characters from C to M now it's
not mandatory to just pattern match on a
single character we can button match on
multiple characters so let me copy this
one let us create a new code block
and let me paste it over here and this
time we can use two characters so let us
pattern match on O and C and next let us
check the contents of rest and let us
try to evaluate this cell and as you can
see we get the right output so you can
see that pattern matching is really very
powerful inside Elixir next you can be
also very specific while pattern
matching with strings you can actually
specify the number of strings that you
want to collect so let me show you an
example right here let us create a new
code block and let me copy this thing
right over here now instead of saying O
and C what we can do is we can say that
we want to create a variable called as
head and inside this variable we want to
collect the first two binaries so here
we can say that we want to collect the
binary and the binary size should be for
two characters next let us check the
output of our head and let us try to
evaluate this one and as you can see we
get the characters of onc back well this
was all about strings inside Elixir now
don't worry if you don't get this
pattern matching with binaries and all
of these things I just wanted to show
you all of the different possibilities
by using pattern matching inside elixir
the next data type is our Char list or
our character list and as I have already
explained the character list is created
by using single quotes so let us create
a variable called as characters and let
us assign the value of octalium now as
you can see I'm using single quotes
right over here
and we get back the value of octallium
now let us do one thing let me copy this
and let us go to our terminal
and inside my IEX I can check for the
information so I can use the inbuilt
function of I and let me paste the
character string right over here and let
us see what kind of output we are
getting
so this time if you see the data type is
actually a list
last time when we were studying about
strings the data type was a binary
string but this is a collection of
characters inside a list and if you want
to see the raw representation so here it
is now please note that as this is a
list we have square brackets at the
start and also at the end and as you can
see each of the characters are also
represented by the integer values so
again the same thing goes 79 represents
o then the value for C is 99 then for T
it is 116 and so on so let us go back to
our live book
next let us see how we can add two
character lists together so let me add a
new blog and here let me create a new
character string and let me say hello
and for adding or concatenating two
lists together we have to use the double
plus symbol and let me pass the
character's value right over here and
let us try to evaluate this cell and
here we get the new value back as hello
octallium just as a reminder for Strings
we were using the angle brackets but
since this is a list that's why we are
using the double plus symbol next we can
also use an inbuilt function to check if
the given characters are indeed a
character list or not so again let me
add a code block and here we can use the
inbuilt function of this list and let us
pass our characters inside of this one
and let us try to evaluate so yes we get
the answer as true and the last point is
we can always check the code point so we
can and use a question mark and then we
can use a character so the code point
value of a would be 97 and if you check
for o it would be 79 and so on so this
was all about characters the next type
that we are going to see is called as
the process so let me take everything up
and here let us add a block and we want
to add a section for process and let us
add a code block right over here now if
you refer to my earlier videos so this
was a video about processes in which I
explained that all of the code is
executed inside processes so these
processes are also a valid type inside
Elixir and we can check the current
process in which our live book is
running so let's create a variable
called as my build so the pit stands for
the process ID and we can use the
inbuilt function of self and let us
check the output of my paid after this
one and let us see what kind of output
we are getting so we get the output as
bid is 144. now if you go back to our
terminal and here let us check the
process in which our IEX is running so
let me call the function of self and
this time we can see that we have a
different bit number the process ID for
our IEX is 107 but if we go back to our
live book we can see that our live book
is running inside the process number
144. now processes and concurrency in
Elixir is a very huge topic and it
requires its own dedicated tutorials but
for this course let us go ahead and let
us see the next type let us add a new
section right over here so I want to add
a new section and this section is all
about our list let me take this thing a
little up so the number one thing that
you need to understand about list is
that the list inside Elixir are actually
linked list and they are not your
regular list so if you try to do
operations like in texting it is not
going to work and just to be precise the
list inside Elixir are actually singly
linked list so let us see how we can
work with list inside Elixir let us
create a new code block right over here
and let us create a list so this is our
list and for a list we can see that we
have the square brackets at the
beginning and at the end and let us try
to evaluate this cell and we get the
list back
now again let me try and repeat that
this list is not your regular array or
not your regular list this is a singly
linked list let's do one small
experiment and let us try indexing on
this list so let us create a new code
block and suppose if I try to see the
element at the zeroth index now let us
see what happens and as you can see we
get an error and we get this error
because this list is actually a linked
list and not your regular list now the
reason that we have linked list inside
Elixir is because linked lists are
recursive in nature your regular arrays
or your regular list they are not
recursive and they have to be saved
continuous in your memory but then how
do we work with listens at Elixir now
there are a lot of mechanisms first and
the obvious one is by using recursive
functions or we can also use a lot of
inbuilt modules so let me show you one
module let me add a code block right
over here and let us take everything up
now we can use the model of enum and we
can say that enum and we can use the
inbuilt function add and let's pass our
list and let us call the index as 0 and
let us see what kind of output we are
getting and here we can see that we get
the output as a so what we are doing is
enum is actually an inbuilt model inside
Elixir and at is a function which is
defined inside the enum module and here
we are simply passing the arguments for
the function let us go back to our IEX
and let me clear up everything let me
make some space from the top and here if
I write enum Dot and if I press tab here
we can see that we have a lot of inbuilt
functions for the enum module and the
function that we use is right over here
add now this Slash 2 actually means the
rity now arity is nothing it's just the
number of arguments that your function
can accept in Elixir we can actually
overload our functions by using
different parameters so for example you
can see right over here we have a
function called as any and for this
function we have two types the first
type is right over here so this function
takes only one argument that's why the
arity is one
and here we have the same function any
but this time it takes two arguments so
that's why the arity is shown as two now
let me clear up all of these things now
let me show you one more helper function
inside Elixir and the name of the
function is H so H stands for your
helper again if you want you can use the
parentheses or you can leave them out
and here we need to specify which model
or which function do we want help for so
what does helper function does is it
simply prints out the documentation for
that module or for that function so here
we need to specify that we want to see
the documentation for the model of enum
and from enum we want to see the
documentation of the function of ADD and
here we get the documentation back the
first line that you can see right over
here this is all about your function
definition and you can see that the
first parameter is actually a
innumerable the second one is the index
and this function also accepts an
optional argument by the name of default
and the default value for this parameter
is nil these two backslashes symbolize
that this argument of default is an
optional argument and in case if this
argument is not specified then the
default value would be simply nil next
we can see that we have a couple of
examples right over here so you can see
that the helper function is very useful
and I often use this function for
reading the documentation inside my
terminal now let us go back to our live
book
and here let us play a little bit more
with pattern matching and with our list
so let me create a new code block now if
you refer our list so our list has three
different elements and we can use
pattern matching to extract all of these
elements
so let me show you how we can do that so
here let me create a couple of different
variables the first one should be called
as first second third you can call this
parameters anything that you want and on
the right I simply want to pattern match
on the list so what's going to happen is
the same old thing the left hand side
should be equal to the right hand side
so the first thing is since this is a
list on the left hand side we do have a
list and we are simply trying to pattern
match on the different elements so this
a would be bound to our variable of
first for the second your B would be
bound and C would be bound to third let
us check out the data inside
second so let me call second right over
here and let me take it up and also let
us try to evaluate this cell and we get
the value back as B now what happens if
you don't want all of the variables and
you simply want to ignore a couple of
them at that time we can simply use an
underscore to ignore the values so
suppose I don't want the values of first
and second then we can do like this so
we can create a list since I want to
ignore the first value I can use and
underscore I also want to ignore the
second value so let me put one more
underscore the next I want to collect
the third value so let me create a
variable called as third and let us
assign a list right over here so our
list is a b and c now let us check the
value inside third and let us try to
evaluate and we get the value as C back
so what happened is since we have an
underscore that's why the value of a is
simply ignored the same thing happens
with BS as well and finally the value of
C gets bound to our variable of third
next let me show you a couple of
convenience function for working with
our list
so the first function is also called as
head so let me show you what I mean so
the head function simply takes the first
value and returns it back so if we call
the inbuilt function of head and let us
pass our list to it and let us try to
evaluate and as you can see we get the
value of a back now similar to head we
also have another function which is
called as tail so let me create a new
code block and the function is called as
tnl now what a tail function is going to
do is it is simply going to ignore the
head value and it will return back all
of the remaining values so let me pass
the variable of list to this one and let
us try to evaluate the cell and we get
back the values of B and C there is also
a shortcut method for doing this so let
me show you how we can do that and this
time we can simply pattern match on our
list so here let us create a list and I
want to pattern match the first value
inside a new variable called as head H
for head and then let me use a cons
operator and then I can say that I want
to collect all of the remaining values
in a new variable called as tail and let
me assign the value of list to this one
next let us check the value inside our
head and let us try to evaluate this
cell and as expected we get a back now
this pipe operator is also known as cons
operator for working with our linked
list next let us also check the value
inside e so let me create a new code
block and let me call the variable of
key and as you can see we simply get
back the remaining values inside our
list the next data type is the Tuple and
we have already seen a couple of
examples of Tuple but let me show you
once again
so the Tuple is created by using the
curly brackets so you can say we want to
create a two element Tuple and we can
say that the values should be 1 and 2.
so this curly brackets are used for
creating an apple not tuples are very
similar to your arrays and all of the
data inside the Tuple is saved
continuously inside the memory and it's
very common to have two or three element
kind of a double but if you want to save
a large number of elements then it is
recommended to go with the list now here
also we can do a simple pattern match so
on the left let's create one more Tuple
we can say A and B and let us check the
value of a and let us try to evaluate
and we get the value back as 1 in this
time let us create a three element Apple
so in the future whenever you are
learning about web development using
Phoenix that time you will see that it's
very common to have three elements or
maximum four elementable and a very
common pattern would be something like
this so the first element would be a
couple called as message the second
element would be the actual message that
you want to send back and the third
element would normally be the state of
your server and let us create a tuple on
the right so the first element should be
reply message could be a string or
Italian phone and for the state we can
pass a simple list of all of the friends
of octallium so we can say octallium
Lewis and Chico next let us try and
print out the message and let us try to
evaluate let's also check the state of
our server so we can say State and let
us try to re-evaluate and we get the
right list back so as you can see tuples
are very convenient data structure
inside Elixir but normally don't use
more than three or four element inside a
tuple the next data type that we are
going to see is also called as the
keyword list so let me show you how a
keyword list looks inside elixir
so we can create a variable called as
data now keyword list is actually a list
but inside the list we have the key and
the value pairs so we can say that a is
1 so a is a key one is a value and you
can say B and 2 and let us try to
evaluate and we get back our keyword
list now what happens inside the keyword
list is your key would normally be an
atom but if you remember we write the
item as colon first and then the name of
the item and in fact this key value pair
is actually saved as a tuple so let me
show you how it is saved as a couple so
here let me create a list and inside the
first element that is the key is always
saved as an atom so I can say a and the
second element is the value so it would
be 1 and let us try and pattern match on
a very simple keyword list so we can say
a and one so as you can see over here a
and colon this is just a convenience
feature but while saving inside the
keyword list it is actually saved as an
atom and this key value pair is
converted into a tuple which we can see
right over here now let us try to
evaluate and we get the same answer back
that means we have a match between the
right hand side and the left hand side
for accessing the different values
inside the keyword list we can use the
inbuilt module so let us go back to our
terminal and let me write keyword Dot
and let me press a tab and as you can
see we have a lot of convenience
features for working with our keywords
let's go back to the live book and let
me show you how to fetch the values from
a given key so for example I can say
that I want to access my keyword list of
data and then I want to access the key
of a and let us try to evaluate and we
get back the data as one well that's it
for this one and we'll learn more about
maps and struck right in the next one
the next data structure that we are
going to study is called as a map
so let me create a variable called as my
map now in the last video we saw how to
create a tuple and for creating a tuple
we normally use the curly brackets and
for creating a map we simply add a
person symbol so maps are more like your
dictionaries in your python these maps
are also your key and value kind of a
data structure but Maps offer a lot of
features as compared to your Tuple or
your keyword list inside Maps we can use
different data types for our keys but
right now let us see how we can use an
atom for our key so we can simply say a
colon and one then let us add one more
element B and let us add one more C and
three so this is how you can create a
map and what happens is when you use a
tuple for your key at that time you can
use the dot notation I will show you
shortly what I mean by the dot notation
but right now let us see how the map
looks like
and we get the map back next we can use
our pattern matching to extract values
so here let me create a map and inside
the map we can pattern match on the key
of A and let us collect the value inside
a variable cordless first next we can
pattern match with b and let us collect
the value inside second and for the last
one we can use the variable of third
and let us pattern match with the
variable of my map
and let us see the value inside the
variable of first and let us try to
evaluate and we get the right answer
back will maps are very convenient data
structure suppose if you want to extract
only the second value you don't have to
use the entire map instead we can do
something like this
so let me just show you let us create a
map and let us say that we simply want
to pattern match on the key of B and let
us collect the value inside second
and latest pattern match with our map of
my map and let us see the value inside
second and as you can see we get the
right answer back so it's not mandatory
to create the entire map to pattern
match instead we can create a shorter
map with just the required elements so
here we are simply pattern matching on
the key of B and we are collecting the
value inside the variable of second the
next thing is since we are using atoms
for our keys we can use our DOT notation
to access the values so let us create a
code block and we can save my map dot a
and it will try to evaluate and we get
the answer back but if we have a
different data type for example if we
have a string for the key values then
you can't use the dot notation
let us create one more map and let me
call it as map 2 and let us create a map
right over here now if you plan to use a
string as your key then we need to write
them inside quotes because they are
strings and since we are using a data
type which is not an item for the key we
need to use the arrow notation and here
we can assign the value as 1 next let us
create one more key for B again remember
since the key is not an atom we are
using the arrow brackets here we can
assign the value of 2 and we can create
the last one C and let us assign the
value of 3 and let us evaluate the cell
and we get our map back next we can use
the same pattern matching techniques so
for example if you want to extract the
value of C then let us create a map and
since this time the keys are strings let
us pattern match right over here and
let's say that we want to collect the
value inside a variable called as C and
let us pattern match with our map number
two and let us see the value inside the
variable of c and we get the right value
back Elixir provides a lot of inbuilt
features for working with our Maps so if
we go back to our terminal and if I
enter map and Dot the tab we can see
that we have a lot of different features
for example if you want to fetch
something or if you want to create a new
map or if you want to replace some
values or if you want to update some
values so we can do a lot of things with
the map
but for now let me show you a very easy
method of updating up a map so let us
create a new code block and suppose we
want to update the value of C from 3 to
4 then we can say that we want to update
the value of our map and the variable
name is map 2 and then we can use the
pipe operator and then we can say that
we want to update the value of C from 3
to 4 and let us bind the value of this
back to our variable of map of 2 and let
us try to evaluate and see what kind of
output we are getting and as you can see
we have updated the value of C now we
are using this arrow notation because we
have strings for our key values but in
case if we have atoms then we can simply
use the colons so let me show you
so we have another map by the name of my
map and then we can say that we want to
update my map and this time we want to
update the value of c and since C is
just an atom we can use the regular
notation and we can say that we want to
update the value to 4 let us try to
evaluate and we get the updated value
back well that's it for this video this
was a very short introduction to Max and
we will learn much more how to work with
maps as we progress in the tutorials the
next video is all about struts in Elixir
the next data type is the struct and if
you come from a compiled programming
language such as C or go you must have
worked with structs and now let us see
how we can create a structure inside
Elixir now for creating a structure we
need to create modules because by
default the structure will take the name
of the module suppose we want to define
a structure for the user then we can
create a module so we can say create
module user and then inside the module
we can use another macro and the name of
the macro is called as depth struct now
all of these things that you can see
over your def module Dev structure these
are all macros that means they create a
code from a given code but right now we
don't have to learn more about macros
let us see how we can define a struct so
what we have defined is we have created
a model called as user and then we are
using another macro called as Dev struct
now here we need to specify the
different fields for our struct and
these fields have to be specified in the
format of your key and value pairs now
here again we can use the bracket
notation if you want or if you don't
want you can leave it out and here let
us see how we can specify the fields so
we can say that the first field should
be username the second one should be an
email now this is one way of specifying
your Fields but if you want to
initialize with some values at that time
we can also pass the key and value pairs
so for example if you want to say that
while initializing we want the age to be
nil and for the email we can say that we
want to have a blank string and for the
username also we can say that while
initializing we simply want to have a
blank string so what we have done is we
have simply converted from a list of
atoms to a list of key value Pairs and
all of these parameters are going to
become the fields for the user struct
next let us see how we can create and
initialize a struct so let me add a code
block now working with struct is very
similar to working with a map for
creating a map we used to use our person
symbol and the brackets and for the
struct is very similar just that we have
to use the name of the strap so this is
how we Define a struct inside let us
specify the different fields so we can
say the value for the username would be
octallium suppose my age is 14 years and
my email can be Autobot at the
redsample.com and let us try and
evaluate
so what we have done is we have
essentially created a struct and this is
how we can initialize a struct structs
behave very similar to our maps and we
can use the same pattern matching
techniques on our struct as well so for
example let us assign this one to a
variable called as user1 and let us
evaluate
next let us create one more code block
and suppose we want to extract the
username then we can simply create your
regular map and here we can say that the
field name would be username and let us
create a variable name and let us
pattern match on the variable of user
one next let us see the value inside
username and let us try to evaluate the
block and as you can see we are getting
the right answer back so what we did was
this user one this is a struct but
structs behave very similar to maps and
that's why we can use our map notation
for pattern matching we can use the same
technique for updating values inside a
struct as well so for example if you
want to update the age so you can say
that the map of my user one and inside
this I want to update the age to suppose
21 and let us rebind the value this back
to user 1 and and let us try and
evaluate and as we can see we get the
updated age back well that's it for this
one so what we have done is till now we
just had a very short introduction to
the different data types in Elixir but
if you're not feeling confident don't
worry as we progress and as you have
more practice you will start feeling
much more confident
till now we have seen a couple of
different data types inside Elixir now
if you're not feeling confident don't
worry we will have more practice as we
progress with the tutorials but right
now let us go with the flow I simply
wanted to introduce you a couple of
topics before we can dive much deeper
into them
the next topic is all about your flow
control inside Elixir for creating Loops
we would normally use recursion but
other than the recursion we have a
couple of different mechanisms for our
flow control so let's have a look at the
first flow control mechanism called as a
case
let us create a simple list so you can
say that the list is going to be one two
and three now what we can do is we can
create a case statement so this case
statement acts more like your switch
statement so let me create a statement
and then I can show you how it works
so here we can say that we want to
create a case and let me put the end
block
now here we can say that we simply want
to fetch the second element from our
list so remember the second element from
our list would be 3 so this is at index
number 0 1 and 2 so we can say that we
want to fetch from the list the second
element and after that depending on the
result of this statement we can pattern
match on a couple of different cases so
let us create the first case inside of
this one so here we can say that in case
this statement evaluates to a one at
that time we simply want to return back
a string and string would be this one
print
next we can also create multiple cases
so in case we get the answer is 3 back
at that time we simply want to return 3
is a match and the next one is a casual
case and for that we can say that we
want to use an underscore that means we
are not interested in the value but in
case we don't have a match for the
return of this statement at that time we
simply want to return a string called as
catch all
now let us try and evaluate this one and
as you can see we get the answer as 3 is
a match so let us try and reiterate what
happened so we have created a key
statement and we simply want to pattern
match on the result of this expression
right over here so this statement
evaluates to a 3 and since we get a
match that's why we get the written as 3
is a match
we can use this case statement to
pattern match on almost anything so for
example suppose we have a structure so
let us create a module so we can say we
want to create a model for post and
inside this let us create a structure
and let us create the different fields
suppose we want to have a field for the
ID and we want to initialize to nil and
then we want one more field for the
title let us initialize to a blank
string the next one could be for the
description and we can again assign it
to a blank string the last one could be
for an author again let us assign a
blank string so we have created a struct
next let us create a post so we can say
that
we want to create a post one and we want
to have a post suppose the ID is one the
title could be title number one the next
we want the author suppose the author is
Julius Caesar
and let us try and evaluate the cell and
as you must have noticed we are not
giving the description inside this
struct but while defining we have
defined that in case we don't have the
value of description at that time we
simply want to initialize it to be a
blank string and that's why we are
getting a blank string right over here
next we can use the case statement for
our post and suppose we want to pattern
match on the author so we can say that
we want to have a case statement and we
want to Pat and match for our post
number one and here let us Define a
couple of different scenarios now
remember that since this is a struct we
can also use the map notation for our
pattern matching so here we can say that
suppose we have an author and in case
the author name is octallium then we
simply want to return a string got a
post from octallium let me copy and
paste suppose the author name is anilo
so we can say got post from Anil
Kulkarni next we can also create a
catch-all blog so we can use the
underscore and this time we can create a
string and we can see what a post from
and we can use the string interpolation
so we can say post one dot author and
let us try and evaluate so this time we
get the answer as got a post from Julius
Caesar not just as a small reminder we
can easily update the struct as you
would update a map so in case we want to
update the author field from Julius
Caesar to my name so we can say that we
want to update the author to become Anil
Kulkarni and let us try to evaluate and
this time we have the new author Anil
Kulkarni now let me create a new code
block and let me just copy and paste the
key statement right over here and let us
try to evaluate oh so this time we are
still getting the answer as Julius
Caesar and that's because we are not
rebinding over here so we can say we
want to rebind the variable of post
number one to the updated value so let
me re-evaluate and this also let us try
to reevaluate and this time we get the
right answer back similar to the case
statement we have another flow control
mechanism by the name of condition so
let me create a new code block over here
and this is going to be for the
condition and here we can define a
couple of different conditions to
pattern match on now the condition
statement does not take an expression
right over here instead we can pattern
match for the different conditions right
over here so suppose the first condition
that we want to match would be for the
Post author and suppose if you want to
say that in case the author is octallium
at that time we simply want to return a
string back saying that editing a post
from octallium let me copy and paste
this one and this time let us check for
the condition of Anil hulkarni and this
also becomes only full currently next
let us also Define the catch all block
for the condition now for defining the
catch or block we simply pattern match
on the true condition and we can say
that in case we have a true condition
then we simply want to return a string
saying that this is a catch all now let
us try to evaluate this cell and we get
back the answer as editing a post from
Anil equal kerning let us have a look at
one more condition block so let me
create a new block right over here we
can also use this condition statement
for more advanced pattern matching so
example we have a list right over here
and
and suppose we want to pattern match on
the first element so at that time what
we can do is we can simply use the head
function so we can say that we want to
extract the head from our list and in
case the head is 1 at that time we want
to return a message saying that got a 1
and let us Define the catch-all block so
this time we can use a string
interpolation and we can say add is and
then we can put the head right over here
so let us invoke the function of head on
the list and let us try to evaluate this
block and we get the answer as got a 1.
so as you can see we can use all of the
different pattern matching techniques
for condition as well as case the last
flow control mechanism is the if and
else block but normally you will not
have to work with the if and else block
we would use recursion or pattern
matching instead of using IF channels
but let me show you how we can use the
if and else blog if required so let me
create a new section this section is for
the if and else and let us create a new
code block so the if and else condition
is pretty much the same so we can say if
true then we want to print out this will
work else we want to print out else this
will work and let us try to evaluate the
cell and we get the answer as this will
work well that's it for all of the
different types of flow control
mechanisms inside Elixir well till now
we had a very short introduction to the
different data types and flow control
mechanisms inside Elixir from the next
video we will start working with a mix
project and at that time we will learn
all of these Concepts in much more
details I think by now we have learned
enough to start with the basic concepts
of functional programming so let us go
ahead and let us start a new project now
Alexa ships with a tool called as mix
which stands for mixing Elixir so this
mix is like your project management tool
so let us see how we can use this to
create our first project so let me go
back to my terminal and I want to go
inside my folder functional programming
with Elixir so right now I have created
only one folder which was for our
Scripts now let me create a new folder
and let me name it as code let me go
inside code
here we can create a new project by
saying mix new and let me name the
project as tutorials
and that's it we have a new Elixir
project let me go inside the folder of
tutorials and let me open it up in my
code editor
so as you can see Elixir by default
creates a bunch of different folders and
files for us so inside the lib directory
we can see that we have a model for the
tutorials let me zoom in for you the
first main topic that we are going to
learn in our journey of functional
programming is all about recursion and
that's what we are going to start right
in the next video
now let's start with the most
fundamental blocks of functional
programming and that is recursion now
don't worry if you have never worked
with recursion or if you find recursion
very confusing I will show you recursion
step by step and line by line I will
also include a lot of diagrams and small
animations to help you understand how
recursion works but for now let us get
started
so this is the mix project that we
created in the last video now I don't
need all of this code let me just take
it out
let me just save it now let's write a
very simple recursive program to print
the number of digits so suppose you have
a function called as up to and if you
pass 3 to it then we should print 0 to
3. so it's a very simple program but we
will Implement a program recursively so
inside the lib directory I want you to
create a new folder by the name of
recursion and inside this folder let us
create a file and let us call it as
print digits dot ex now this time please
remember that the extension is dot ex
because we want to compile this file and
if you go to test here we can see that
we have dot EXs so this are script files
and they are not meant for your
production code now let me get back to
the print digits and let me collapse my
sidebar now remember that all of the
code inside Elixir stays inside its
modules so the first thing is we need to
define a model for this file so let's
create a model by typing depth module
and this is the name recursion dot print
digits but the naming convention goes
like this first we normally include the
name of our project so we have to name
our project as tutorials and let me open
up my sidebar so inside our project of
tutorials we have created a folder
called as recursion and inside that
recursion we have created a file called
as print digits now remember that this
is just a community convention and it is
not required you can name this model
anything that you want now with that in
mind let me collapse my sidebar now
inside of this module let us create a
function called as up to so we can
define a function by using the keyword
of Def and then we can say up to now
this function is going to accept one
parameter and that would be for our
numbers and then we can start with the
do and end blocks now suppose the number
is 3 then we simply want to print out
something thing like this so we take the
input as 3 and then we want to print
digits from 0 to 3 so this is what we
want to print but we need to do this
thing recursively you must be thinking
maybe we can just create a for Loop so
we can create a for Loop for I is equal
to 0 then we can say I less than a and
equal to your number and then I plus
plus and then we can simply print out I
so if you're thinking we can do
something like this then the answer is
no because all of the data types inside
Elixir are constants they are immutable
and what's happening inside the for Loop
is for each iteration we are changing
the value of I which is right over here
so we can't use this kind of for Loops
inside Elixir then what can we use so
the answer is by using recursion
so let me take out the comments first
let me write the code and then I will
explain what's happening now let's think
of a base case suppose the number itself
is 0 then at that time we don't have to
do anything so at that time we simply
have to return back zero so we just
write 0 over here now remember that the
last line inside of function
automatically returns so this is your
automatic return statement and we don't
have to use the keyword of return for
the last line now remember that Elixir
is a functional programming language so
essentially we have to return some kind
of a value for each function and in case
the function is creating some kind of a
side effect at that time by default an
item of ok is returned but for now let
us continue with this program and let me
write the next base case so what we can
do in Elixir is we can actually create
multiple copies of the same function
this is also called as function
overloading and we can do this because
Elixir supports pattern matching so what
we did right over here is we created a
function called as up to and we are
pattern matching on zero so in case if
the number is 0 then we simply want to
return 0 and that's it now we can create
one more copy of the same function so we
can say Define up to this again accepts
a parameter called as numbers and let's
see what we can do this time so this
time what we want to do is we simply
want to print out so we can print out by
using i o dot puts so let us print out
the number but what we want to do is for
each iteration we want to reduce the
number by one so for example if the
number was 3 then after we print out 3
for the next iteration your number
should become 2 then your number should
become 1 and then your number should
become zero and when your number becomes
0 at that time we go to this line number
three where we simply return 0 back so
the the next question is how can we
reduce the value of number by 1 each
time the answer is by using a recursive
call to the same function so for each
iteration we can call ourselves back but
each time what we can do is we can say
numbers minus of one so what we are
doing is suppose this number is 3 so the
next time when we call the same function
we are passing 3 minus 1 that means we
are passing 2 now don't worry if you
find this logic a little bit confusing
we will see how to trace this function
and how we can create recursive trees so
I will use a small diagram and small
animation for it but first let us run
this file and let us see if it is
working or not so let me save the file
and let me open up my terminal now till
now we have been working with IEX but
this time we have created a project by
using our mix tool but fortunately we
can use IEX along with our mix project
as well so here we can you can see that
hey IX I want you to start mix so we
just use the flag of hyphen and S
followed by the mix command
so what happens in the background is IEX
simply compiles your project and all of
the modules are available to you inside
our IEX so let me clear up everything
and let us call this function of up to
but remember that this function stays in
this module so what we can do is we can
say from the model of tutorials I want
you to go to the model of recursion from
Recreation I want you to go to the model
of print digits and from here I want to
use the function of up to and let us
pass 3 right over here and let us see
the output we are getting so here it is
we are getting the output of 3 2 and 1
so this 0 is not printing if you want we
can print 0 right here at line number
four so if you want we can replace this
line by again io.puts and 0 but I think
there is no point in printing 0 so we
can take this one out or else we can
also say that whenever we get a 0 we
simply want to stop and we can return
back an atom called as okay which
symbolizes that our operation was
successful now let me save the file now
since we have saved the file we also
need to recompile our project now here
we have two choices either we can
recompile the entire project or we can
decompile just the model that we have
changed but each time typing such a huge
model name is a big pain in the ass so
what we can do is we can create a small
Alias so we can say that I want to
create an alias for tutorials dot
recursion dot print digits let me clear
up the screen and now we can say that I
simply want to recompile my model of
print digits and here it is we have
recompiled that module now let me clear
it up one more time and this time again
we can use the model of print digits and
we can invoke the function of up to now
again if you want you can use the
parentheses or or you can leave them out
so let me just pass three right over
here and this time we get the output of
3 2 1 and okay so let us go back to our
code editor and let us see what's
happening so what's happening right over
here is this is also called as your base
case so let me put a comment right over
here so this you can call this is your
base case so that means that in case if
we get an input which is 0 at that
moment we simply want to return some
kind of a value and we want to exit from
our recursive function now since this
function returns a single value we can
use a much shorter syntax so let me take
out and let me take out the written
statement and after the function
definition I have to put a comma after
do I have to put a colon and let me take
out the OK from here and let me paste it
right over here and that's it so this is
also a valid function definition so
normally whenever we written a single
value that time we use a single line
definition now instead of returning okay
let me go back to returning zero so
what's happening is we have a base case
whenever we are getting the input of 0
at that time we are simply returning 0
but we are not printing anything and in
all other cases we are first printing
that number and then we have a recursive
call now let's see how we can trace this
function so let me open up my browser
and uh so this is our function for print
digits so this print up to 0 and do 0
this is our base case and this is our
recursive function so this line number
four is a place where actual printing is
taking place and on line number five we
have a recursive call to the same
function now let's see how we can trace
this function just imagine that the
first argument we are passing to this
function is 3 so for each iteration
what's going to happen so Elixir is
going to compare from top to the bottom
is 3 and 0 equal no they are not so
Elixir will jump to this function
definition so let's see what's going to
happen for this function definition the
first thing is we are simply telling
Elixir to print out the value of number
so that's what is going to happen so the
first call is to print and we get three
back now what happens next so next is a
recursive call to the same function but
with the value of number minus 1 so
let's see what's going to happen so next
is we are calling the same function back
but the value becomes 2 now is 2 equal
to 0 no it's not equal to zero so again
Elixir will jump to this function
definition and again what happens the
first line is we simply want to print
out the number so we get the output of 2
and what happens on the next line we are
calling ourself back but this time again
number minus 1 so the next call becomes
up to and your argument becomes 1. again
the same thing happens is 1 equal to 0
no it's not so again Elixir will jump to
this function definition the first line
is to print the value so we get the
value of 1 back now what happens over
here again we have to call ourselves
back so again we call the same function
but this time the argument becomes 0
remember 1 minus 0 that's why we get the
argument here as 0. now again Elixir
jumps to first Clause now remember
Elixir scans your code from top to the
bottom and the first definition is up to
with a pattern match of zero and this
time what's happening is we have a match
since up 2 gets a parameter of 0 we
simply want to return 0 back so what's
going to happen over here
so for this function we are simply going
to return 0 back and that's it do we
have any other calls left no so we
simply exit and that's it we have the
display of 3 to 1 in our console so let
me open up my terminal one more time and
here it is we have the exact same output
of 3 2 and 1.
so what we did right over here is we saw
how we can trace our recursive program
so always remember to plot this kind of
trees and this will help you to
understand recursive programming in a
much better way now let us go back to
the code
and this time let me make a very small
change now instead of printing the
number first what happens if I print the
number afterwards now let's see what
happens this time let me open up my
terminal one more time and let us
recompile our model since we changed the
code and let me clear it up and then let
me again call the print digits up to and
let us pass three so this time what
happened so instead of getting the
output of 3 2 and 1 we have the output
of 1 2 and 3 so what happened we simply
change one line right over here and our
entire output got reversed so let us go
back and try to trace this circus
program as well
so this was the earlier one and this is
going to be the new one so remember we
have the print statement afterwards but
first we are calling the function
recursively so let's see what's going to
happen this time so again suppose that
we are passing the argument of 3 so what
happens is 3 equal to 0 No 3 is not
equal to 0 then Elixir will jump to this
function definition now what's happening
in this definition first we are calling
ourselves so what's going to happen we
have a recursive call and the parameter
becomes 3 minus 1 that means we have a
parameter called as 2 but what happens
to this call at line number five nothing
that statement remains unexecuted
because first we have to exhaust this
function right over here so what's going
to happen next time so let us see right
over here so this call right over here
this does not execute instead first we
have to exhaust all of the parameters
for this function now what's happening
the parameter is 2 is 2 equal to 0 no
it's not so we are going to go in this
function definition so what's happening
this time we again have a recursive call
so let us call ourselves back but this
time the argument becomes one and what
happens to the print statement nothing
that is kept on hold right over here now
let us go back to this function right
over here is 1 equal to 0 no so we go to
this function again what happens we have
to call ourselves back so let us call
ourselves back but this time the
argument becomes 0 and what happens to
the print statement again that is kept
pending now what's going to happen this
time we are calling ourselves but the
argument is zero so we have a pattern
match right over here and whenever the
argument is 0 we simply give back 0 and
that's what happened right over here so
this call right over here this resulted
in a zero now the control will go back
to the previous function now what is
spending in the previous function this
print statement is pending but what is
the value of number so the value of
number 1 that's why we get the output of
1 first now again we have exhausted this
Clause the control will go back to this
one again what's pending the print
statement is pending but what is the
value of Number the value of numbers 2
that's why we get the output as 2. now
again this function is exhausted so the
control goes back to this function right
over here again what's pending the print
statement is pending but what is the
value of number it's 3 that's why we get
the value of 3 back and this is exactly
happening right over here so we get the
value of 1 2 and 3 so what's happening
over here is we can say that our print
statement is executing in the return
stage but in the earlier example our
print statement was executing in the
ascending stage so we have a basic
difference in the execution of our
recursive functions let us try and
summarize what we have learned till now
so what we have done is we have created
a simple program to print out the digits
but we have implemented the logic in a
recursive function now the only line of
difference is right over here in the
first time the recursive call is the
last line inside this function now
remember the last line is automatically
returned we don't have to use the
keyword of return and this is creating a
loop for us now when do we exit we exit
when we have a base case and what is the
base case it's criteria whenever we get
a 0 at that time we simply want to
return 0 and this is the time when we
exit from our recursive function so we
have two different function definitions
the first definition is for our base
case the second definition is for our
recursive case now what we did in the
second time is we simply change our
recursive call so in the second case
first we have a recursive call and then
we have the print statement and what
happened this time the execution shifted
from ascending stage to the written
stage so if I have to summarize further
here what's happening the printing is
done in ascending stage and in the
second case the printing is done in the
return stage that means the work or the
execution happened during the return and
not during ascending stage so this kind
of function is also called as yield
recursion now remember in tailed
Recreation we are calling the same
function back but each time with a
different argument and on the second
case this recursion is called as head
recursion because first we have the
recursive call and then we have some
kind of an execution left now you can
see that we can create efficient Loops
in Elixir by using recursion and that
too avoiding all of the side effects by
mutating our values well that's it for
this one I hope you enjoyed the lecture
on recursion and I will catch you in the
next one so till now we saw how to print
digits by using recursion and we sort
two methods that was tail recursion and
head recursion now let us get some more
practice with recursion and this time
instead of just printing the digits let
us add all of the digits together
so for example let us create a function
called as up to and if you pass the
argument of 3 at that time we want to
get the sum of all of the digits so this
function should return 3 plus 2 that is
5 5 plus 1 is 6 so this function should
return as 6. so let us go ahead and let
us create the file for this one so
inside the directory of recursion let me
create a new file and let me call it as
sum of digits dot e x the first thing we
want to define a module and as per the
community convention let us write the
application name first so the
application name is tutorials and then
the folder is recursion and then the
file name is sum of our digits let me
collapse my sidebar now here let me
first write a very simple recursive
function and then we will try and
restart function so let us call a
function by the name of up to and let us
pass the argument for the numbers and
let's see what we can do this time so
this time we can use a very simple
recursive function we can say that for
each iteration I simply want to add the
number and the next time I want to call
the same function of up to but every
time my argument should be number minus
of 1 but this function will never end
because we don't have a base condition
the number will keep on going into
negative values so we also need to
define a base condition so on the top
let us create the base condition so let
me create a new function by the name of
up to and this time let us pattern match
on 0 suppose the number is 0 then at
that time I simply want to return back
0. now remember if we have a single line
of return then we can write it on the
same line and in case if we have a
regular function then the last line is
automatically returned we don't have to
use the keyword of return so let me save
the file first let me run the file and
then we will try and Trace the recursive
function so let me open up my terminal
and let us enter inside IEX so I can say
IEX dot s that stands for start I want
IEX to start my mix and let me clear all
of these things let us create an alias
so we can say I want to create an alias
for tutorials dot recursion dot sum
digits let me clear up the screen and
now we can see from the model of some
digits I want to use the function of up
to and let me pass the argument of three
so as expected we get the answer as 6 so
what happened 3 plus 2 plus 1 is equal
to 6 now let us see how we can trace
this recursive function so this is our
program for some digits and this is the
functions that we wrote on line number
one we have the base case and on line
number three we have the recursive case
now let us see what's going to happen
let's take the same example and let us
pass 3 to this function now is 3 equal
to 0 No 3 is not equal to 0 so Elixir
will go to the next function and here
what's going to happen here we are
saying that we want to add the number
and after adding the number we simply
want to call the function recursively so
what's going to happen is we get 3 plus
and again we call back the same function
but this time the argument is number
minus one that's why the next time we
are calling the same function up to with
an argument of 2. now what's going to
happen is 2 equal to 0 no so elixir go
to the next function now what happens
again the same thing number plus the
recursive call
so what's going to happen is so this
will evaluate 2 we get the number so the
number in this case is 2 so 2 and plus
and then we again get back the recursive
function but this time the argument is 2
minus of 1 that's why the argument
becomes 1. now again let us go back to
the same function is 1 equal to 0 no
then we will go to the next function now
here again the same thing repeats so
this time again the number plus that
means 1 plus and let us call the same
function again but this time the
argument becomes 0 so what's going to
happen this time this time we have a
base condition in place which is right
over here we are saying that whenever
the argument is 0 at that time we simply
want to return back zero so this
function right over here this will
simply return back a 0. so now what has
happened we have exhausted this call and
now the control has to return back to
the earlier functions so what what's
going to happen so this entire
expression 1 plus of this function this
will be evaluated to 1 plus 0 is equal
to 1 so this entire expression evaluated
to a one now the control will go back to
this function right over here but this
time what's happening so this entire
function call evaluated to a 1 so what's
going to happen right over here this
entire expression would be evaluated to
2 plus 1 is equal to 3. now again the
control will go back to the earlier
function call so this time what's
happening the function call of up to and
2 has evaluated into a three so this
entire expression gets evaluated to 3
plus of 3 that means we get back a 6 and
this is what is written from our
function which you can see right over
here now if you have a look at this
function this function is neither head
recursive neither it is still recursive
it is just a recursive function but can
we convert this function into a tail
recursive function yes we can so let me
show you how we can convert this
function from a regular function to our
tail recursive function so let us create
a new function right over here and we
can say that this time the up to
function would be tail recursive now
first let me write the function
definition and then I will explain
what's happening so this function is
going to accept two different parameters
the first parameter is the number as it
is and I also want to accept one more
parameter which I am going to call as
accumulator so which stands for ACC for
short next let us think of our base
condition so as we just saw over here we
have a base condition where the number
is zero so let's try and replicate that
same logic right over here so in case if
I say that my number itself is 0 then at
that time I simply want to return back
my accumulator so I can say do ACC e so
this is our base condition now let us
see how we can Define our recursive
condition so let me copy and paste right
over here and this time we want to get a
number and let us take the return
statement in a different line so let me
take it out now let's see what we can
use as our recursive call now again
please let me repeat first let me write
the code and then when we see how to
trace the recursive algorithm at that
time the logic will get clear but right
now what I want to do is I simply want
to call the same function again but for
each iteration I want to say that my
number has to decrease by 1 and for each
iteration I simply want to add my
accumulator with the number and that's
it we are done so let me save the file
and let me open up the terminal and now
I can recompile the model of some digits
now let me clear up the screen and we
can say that we want to use the tail
recursive version and let me pass 3 to
this one oh we have an error that's
because we also need to pass the
accumulator so this function the tail
recursive requires two arguments and I
pass only a single argument that's why
we get an error so let me clear this up
and we can say that the accumulator has
to be 0 and this time we get the answer
back as 6. now we can slightly improve
our program each time instead of passing
an accumulator what I can do is I can
simply set the default values so let us
go back to the code editor and let me
copy and paste this line so what we are
going to do is we are going to create a
function definition and since we are
just creating the function definition or
you can say just the function header we
don't need to specify the return
statement so this has to go and here we
can say that the default value of the
accumulator is 0 so in case the
accumulator is not specified at that
time the accumulator would be set to 0
and here instead of 0 we can say that
the first argument can be any number so
what we have done right over here is we
have simply created a public function so
as our code editor is helping us it's
just a public function with a given name
and body so normally these things they
help you with the documentation of your
code the first thing we again need to
recompile our model of some digits let
me clear up the screen and let us try to
invoke the same function but this time
since we have a default argument for the
iPhone emulator I can simply leave it
out and again we get the same answer
back as 6. before we go ahead and trace
this recursive function we can do one
small thing now what happens this
function is slightly expensive because
it takes slightly more memory so what we
can do over here is we can simply call
the tail recursive function and pass the
argument of number and that's it so now
let us open up our terminal and let us
again recompile let me clear up
everything and this time if I do some
digits dot up to and if I pass the
argument of 3 so what's happening behind
the scenes we are still invoking the
tail recursive function and we are
getting the same answer back as six so
now let us go ahead and let us see how
we can trace the tail recursive function
so this was the last function now if we
want to trace the tail recursive
function on line number two we just have
the function definition so this function
accepts a number and for accumulator we
have set the default value as 0 on line
number three we have the base condition
and we are saying that whenever we get
the number as 0 at that time we simply
want to return back the accumulator the
next is our recursive call now let us
pass the argument of 3 to this function
and let us try to trace this recursive
function so we have an initial call like
this the value of number is 3 and by
default the accumulator is set to 0. now
let's see what's happening now is 3
equal to 0 no it's not equal to 0 so
Elixir will go to this function right
over here now what's happening now we
are calling the same function back okay
so what we need to do we need to call
the same function back but what happens
to the argument so the first argument is
we simply want to decrement the number
by one so in this condition what is
happening the number is 3 okay so we get
3 over here and for each call we simply
want to subtract one from it so the
answer here is 2 and the next parameter
is right over here so we simply want to
add the accumulator with the number
so let's go right over here so what's
the accumulator so as you can see
initially the accumulator is zero so we
get a zero right over here what's the
number the number is 3 so 0 plus 3 we
get a 3 right over here so this entire
function would look something like this
the new number is 2 and the new
accumulator is a 3. now let's see what's
going to happen is 2 equal to 0 no it's
not so we will go inside this function
again we have to recursively call the
same function so let us see what's going
to happen so again we call the same
function but this time what happens the
number is -1 so this 2 comes over here
minus of 1 so what's the remainder it's
one the next is accumulator plus the
number so in this case what is the
accumulator the accumulator is 3 which
comes right over here what is the number
number is 2 so 2 comes over here so 3
plus 2 we have a five so this function
gets evaluated 2 right over here up to
the number becomes 1 and accumulator
becomes 5. now again the same thing we
have to call ourselves back again now is
1 equal to 0 no so we go to the next
condition and again we call ourselves
back so what's going to happen this time
so this time number is 1 1 minus or 1 so
that's why we get a 0 right over here
the next is again the same thing
accumulator plus the number so what's
the accumulator the accumulator is 5
that's why we get a 5 over here what's
the number the number is 1 so we get a 1
over here so 5 plus 1 we get a 6 that
means we can say that this expression is
evaluated something like this up to 0
and 6 oh so this time the number becomes
zero so what's going to happen so it's
going to go right over here so is the
number 0 yes the number is zero so what
do we do we simply written back in the
accumulator so that's what is going to
happen right over here we simply have to
return back the accumulator so what's
the accumulator the accumulator is 6 and
that is what we have written so now is
anything left nothing nothing is left
and that's it we get the answer back as
six so as you can see this tail
recursive functions are very special the
first reason is they require less memory
and why do they require less memory is
because they are recursively calling
themselves back again now if you come
from some other compiled language like
Java or maybe like python you must be
thinking that for each of these calls V
must be allocating different stack
memory but no that does not happen in
Elixir since Elixir is a functional
programming language this function calls
are highly optimized so what's happening
we are simply reusing the same stack and
hence there is no extra memory
allocation so always whenever possible
try and use skill recursive functions
because they are more memory efficient
in terms of speed it could be more it
could be less you don't know but in
terms of memory for sure they require
much less memory well that's it for this
video and I will catch you in the next
one let's have some more practice with
our recursion in the last video we wrote
a very simple recursive program to
calculate the sum of the different
digits but for this video I want you to
calculate the factorial of a number
first let me get this back to the old
code so the old code was number plus of
up to and then we simply want to call
number minus of one so this time what I
wanted to do is I wanted to write a
program for calculating factorial so for
example if we have a number like 3 then
the factorial would be like this 3 into
2 into 1 and the output would be 6. so I
wanted to pause this video for movement
and try it on your own so I hope you
were able to do it if not let us do it
together
so first let me create a new file and
let me call that file as
factorial.ex and first let us create the
module let us get the model name right
this has to be tutorials dot recursion
dot factorial and here let me create a
function called as off so we can simply
call factorial dot off so the first
condition is in case if I get 1 at that
time I simply want to return one back
next let us write the recursive case so
in case we get some other number so we
can say number and this time let me show
you how you can calculate by using a
regular recursive program and after that
I will also show you how to write this
program by using TLD recursion but for
now let us go with the flow so here we
can say that for each iteration we want
to multiply a number and we simply want
to call ourselves back each time but
each time we want to decrement the
number by 1 so this is a very simple
recursive case let us open up our
terminal let me clear up everything and
let us use our IX let me adjust my
terminal as well here we can create an
alias so we can say tutorials dot
recursion dot factorial and let's call
our function so we can say factoidal off
and let us pass 3 so we get the answer
as 6 let us try with 4 so we get the
answer as 24 back now let us try and
trace this recursive program and see
what's happening so this is the first
recursive program that we wrote so here
we have the base condition Define off if
we get one we simply want to return one
otherwise we want to call this function
so now let us try and Trace what's
happening so suppose we invoke this
function with an argument of 3 so at
that time what's going to happen so is 3
equal to one no so Elixir will go to
this function and now what's going to
happen we have to multiply the number
and call the function itself again so
here it goes we want to multiply 3 and
we want to call the same function one
more time but since we are decrementing
the number by 1 so this time the
argument becomes 2. now again is 2 equal
to 1 no so we will jump to this function
again the same thing will happen we
first have to multiply the number and
call the same function one more time so
this time again we have 2 and this time
2 multiplied by the same function and
the new argument is 1. so in the next
iteration we have a match on the base
case so since we have a match we simply
have to return one so this function
would be evaluated to a simple one now
the control will go back to this
statement right over here 2 multiplied
by and this function so this would be
evaluated to 2 and this one comes right
over here so this entire expression
would be evaluated to a 2. now the
control will again flow back right over
here so this one would be evaluated
something like this 3 multiplied by 2
and we have a 6. now there is nothing on
the top we have exhausted dysfunction as
well that's why we get the written value
as 6 which is the factorial of 3. now
let's go back to our program
so this was a very simple recursive way
of creating the factorial next is can
you write the same program but by using
tail regression so if you can just give
it a pause and try it on your own
otherwise I will show you how we can
write the same program by using tail
recursion so let me create a new
function right over here and I can say
off but this time it's going to be with
real recursion this function is going to
accept two arguments so the number one
would be on number and for the tail
recursive function first let us create
the base case so here we can pattern
match on the number so we can say that
in case the number is 1 and the second
argument is our accumulator so this time
I simply want to return back my
accumulator so don't worry if you don't
understand we will trace this program as
well next comes our recursive case so we
can say of our tail recursive version so
the first argument is our number the
second argument is our accumulator so
here I can say that for each iteration I
simply want to call the same function
again so off tail recursion but for each
iteration I simply want to decrement my
number by 1 and for each iteration I
also want to multiply my accumulator
with my number next we can do one slight
Improvement for this program as well we
can also have a default value for the
accumulator so let us go ahead and let
us create the function definition on the
top so remember that the function
definition always goes on the top so
here we can say we want to Define of our
tail recursive function the first
argument is always going to become the
number the second argument is our
accumulator and for the accumulator we
want to have the default value of 1 and
since this is just a function definition
we don't have to write the body of this
function and let me open up my terminal
and since we have changed the contents
of the module first let us try and
recompile this module now let me clear
up everything now let's try and use the
tail recursive version so we can say
factorial of this time we want to use
our Delta cluster function and let us
pass the argument of three so we get the
answer back as 6. let us try one more
time with 5 and for 5 we get the answer
as 120 so now let us go and try and
trace this recursive program as well so
this is our tail recursive version so as
you can see for the first line we have
the function definition the first
argument is the number and we have the
default value for the accumulator and
the default value is 1 next we have the
base case and here we simply want to
pattern match on the number so we are
saying that in case the number is 1 at
that time I simply want to return back
my accumulator next we have our
recursive case so for each iteration we
simply want to decrement the number by 1
and we also want to multiply our
accumulator with the number so now let
us see what's going to happen with this
one suppose we invoke the function with
an argument of 3 and the default value
for the accumulator is 1 so for the next
iteration what's going to happen so is 3
equal to 1 no so Elixir is going to jump
right over here so what's going to
happen this time we want to call
ourselves back so this function will
call itself back but this time the first
argument is number minus 1 so 3 minus 1
that's why we get a 2 right over here
and for the next R command we simply
want to multiply the accumulator with
the number the accumulator is 1 the
number is 3 so we get a 3 right over
here so this function would look
something like this so next again so is
2 equal to 1 no so we have to call
ourselves one more time so again this
time what's going happen is we want to
decrement the number by one so this
evaluates to a 1 and we also want to
multiply the accumulator with the number
so the accumulator is 3 and the number
is 2 so we get a 6 right over here and
this function would look something like
this what's going to happen this time oh
so this time we have a match on the
number and we are pattern matching and
saying that in case the number is 1 at
that time we simply want to return the
accumulator so this function would
evaluate to something like this we
simply have to return back the
accumulator and the accumulator is 6 and
that's your final answer and after this
we simply exit because there is nothing
else left to do so just as a small tip
whenever you are feeling confused with
recursion or if you don't know what's
happening inside your recursive calls
it's always a good idea to draw this
kind of recursive trees and for sure
they will help you to understand
recursion in a much better way well
that's it for this video and I will
catch you in the next one let's have
some more practice with our recursion
and this time I wanted to write a
program that will reverse the numbers so
in case the number is one two three then
the output should be 3 2 and 1. and what
I've done is behind the scenes I've
created a new file called as reverse
number inside recursion and I have
created a blank model for this one now
here you can use your own logic to
reverse the number or if you want some
reference I have given a simple
algorithm right over here but it's not
required to follow my logic if you can
do it in any other way you are welcome
to do it so let's see what steps I have
given right over here so for example the
number is 123 then the output should be
321 so for this case suppose I want to
write a tail recursive version at that
time I want to have one more variable
called as accumulator and I want to set
at the default value of accumulator 0.
now again it's not necessary for you to
write a tail recursive version you can
write any version that you seem fine but
I am going to write a tail recursive
version for this one that's why I have
taken one more variable next what I am
doing is I am creating a loop and for
each iteration I want to create a new
number and a new accumulator so let's
see what's going to happen for the new
number and for the new accumulator for
each iteration of the loop I simply want
to divide this number by 10 so that I
get a new number each time so for the
first time the number is 123 so 123
divided by 10 so I get the answer as 12.
now for the new accumulator there are
two steps the first step is I simply
want to multiply my existing accumulator
by 10. now the existing accumulator is 0
so 0 multiplied by 10 that's why I have
a 0 right over here so this was the
first part and the next part is I also
want to take the remainder of this
number so I'm using the mod operator so
here what's going to happen is the
remainder of 123 and 10 is 3 and the
final step is 0 plus of 3 and we get a 3
right over here the next thing is I want
to continue with this Loop till the time
my number becomes 0 but right now my
number is 12 so this number changes from
123 to 12 and the new accumulator is 3
that's why this 0 changes to a 3. now is
my number equal to 0 no so we continue
with the loop so for the next iteration
our number is 12 so 12 divided by 10 we
get a 1 right over here and for the new
accumulator the value inside the
accumulator is 3 so 3 multiplied by then
we get a 30 right over here for the next
part the number is 12 the remainder of
12 and 10 is 2 so here we have 30 plus
of 2 that's why this will evaluate to
32. now again is my number equal to 0 no
my new number is 1 and my do accumulator
is 32 so we continue with the same Loop
now this time my number is 1 so 1
divided by 10 I get a 0 right over here
then for the new accumulator my value
inside the accumulator is 32 so as you
can see right over here we have 32 so 32
multiplied by 10 that's why we get 320
right over here the next part is the
number is 1 the remainder of 1 and 10
becomes 1 so here we have 1 plus of 320
so we get 3 2 and 1 right over here so
what happens now your number number has
become 0 and your accumulator has become
321 and since your number becomes 0 we
simply want to return back the
accumulator and the accumulator is 3 to
1 which is exactly the reverse of 123.
now before you attempt this question let
me show you one more thing in Elixir if
you do something like this 123 divided
by 10 here you can see that we get back
a float value but if you want to get
back an integer division then you can
use the inbuilt function of div for for
division so we can say we want to divide
123 by 10 and we get back in the integer
value of 12. now for calculating the
remainder we don't have the modulus
operator instead you can use the inbuilt
function of remainder so we can say that
we want to get the remainder of 123 with
10 and we get back to the value of 3. so
with these things in mind I want you to
write this program now again let me
repeat you can use your own logic and
just pause this video for a moment and
try it on your own otherwise we will do
it together
so I hope you were able to do it if not
let us do it together I am going to
write a tail recursive version for this
program and the first thing which I want
to do is I simply want to Define my base
case and what is my base case my base
case is right over here so if my number
is 0 then I simply want to return the
accumulator let me create a function
called as off and this function is going
to accept two parameters by number and
my accumulator and my base case is
something like this in case my number is
0 then I simply want to return back my
accumulator so this is our base case now
let us Define the recursive case so we
can say that the function of off is
going to accept one parameter for the
number the second one for the
accumulator and let us create the do and
end blocks here we can say that my new
number is going to be the integer
division of my number with n n and also
for each iteration I want to create a
new accumulator so I can say that my new
accumulator again let us use the logic
that we have defined over here so the
logic goes like this for each iteration
I simply want to multiply the
accumulator with n and for the next part
we simply want to add the remainder of
the number along with 10. now the only
thing left to do is to Simply call the
same function one more time but this
time the argument is going to be our new
number and here we have the new
accumulator now here we also need to set
the default value of accumulator to 0 so
let me create a function definition on
the top so we can say that function of
off accepts one parameter by the name of
number the second parameter is called as
accumulator the default value is 0 now
since this is just the function
definition we don't have to create the
body let me save this program let me
open up my terminal null now since this
time I have added a new file let us
recompile the entire project so we can
say that I want to decompile then let me
create an alias for tutorials dot
recursion dot reverse number oh sorry I
spelled it wrong so it has to be
alias
let me clear up the screen and now let
us try our newly defined function
so we can say that reverse number off
and let us pass the argument of 123 and
we get the right answer back let us try
with one two three four five and we get
back the answer of 5 4 3 to 1. till now
we have seen how to work with recursion
inside our Elixir now it's time to see
how we can combine list along with our
Elixir and I can't emphasize more that
the list inside Elixir are not your
regular arrays or lists list inside
Elixir are actually linked list so even
if a list looks something like this it's
not what it looks like so for those of
you who don't know what is a linked list
here it goes so here we have three
different nodes and for the first node
the data inside the head is one so as
you can see the data inside the list
this one this one actually looks
something like this inside the memory so
this enter bad thing this would be your
node number one and the data inside your
head would be one the darker portion
that you can see over here so this is
going to be your tail of your node
number one and this tail is actually
pointing to yet another node and the
data inside this node is stored that you
can see over here so this entire
structure this is our node number two
and the data inside the head is two now
again this node also has a tail and this
tail is pointing to yet another node the
data inside the node is 3 and as you can
see this is going to be our node number
three The Head and the data inside the
head is three now if you have a look at
the list we don't have any other
parameters left so the tail of your node
number three this would actually point
to something which is null that means it
is not pointing to anything else so this
is how a linked list would look inside
the memory now just to refresh your
memory let us go back to our terminal so
we can say that we have a list and the
elements are 1 2 and 3. now as we just
saw we have three different nodes and if
you want to see the head of the first
element then either you can use the
built-in function for the head or we can
also use pattern matching and in case if
you want to use the pattern matching
then we can say that the first element
should be head then we need our cons
operator then we need one more variable
for the tail and let us pattern match on
list and here we can see that the head
is 1 and the tail is 2 and 3. now
suppose we have one more list let us
call it as list number two and this has
a single element of a inside of this
list now what happens if I try to
pattern match on this list so let us
pattern match and see let us write the
head and we also want the tail and this
time we want to pattern match on list
number two so as you can see the data
inside our head is a but what happens to
your tail let us check it out so as you
can see the tail is blank that means we
have exhausted this linked list and
there are no more elements left so keep
this pattern in your mind and we will
see how to work with recursion and lists
right from the next video
so let us get started with linked list
but before we can get started I wanted
to show you a couple of things
so let us go back to our terminal and I
am inside my IEX
now in case if I want to see the info
for a list so let's create a list one
two and three
here we get back a couple of information
parameters for our list and here we can
see that we have a couple of implemented
protocols and one of the most important
protocol is this one so this stands for
innumerable that means in short as enum
and let us go to the official
documentation and there I can explain
all of these things
so this is the official website for
Elixir it's
elixirland.org let us go to docs and
here we want to see the documentation of
the current stable version so this takes
us to a new website and as you can see
this website is called as hex docs.pm so
hex is like the package registry for
Elixir so in case if you go to this
website hex dot pm and here we can
search for different packages suppose
you want to search for Phoenix then you
can search for Phoenix right over here
and this is going to list all of the
packages so this is the official package
for Phoenix and if you click on the
online documentation it will take you to
the docs page and this is the official
documentation for Phoenix now let us go
back to the documentation for Elixir and
as you can see we have two tabs right
over here so this tab is for the pages
and this tab is for the modules now this
model of Kernel is automatically
imported for us we don't have to import
this kernel the next model which I
wanted to show you is for our list
so let us scroll a little bit down and
inside this section of Collections and
enums we have our list right over here
and here we can see that we have nice
documentation in place and also we have
a couple of functions that are
implemented on the type of list so here
we can see we have different functions
and if you want to see documentation for
any of the functions you have to just
click on this one and this open UPS the
documentation for the requested function
now in the terminal we saw that list
also implements the protocol for our
enum so let us check out the
documentation for enum let me collapse
my list and let us go to the
documentation for erum so enum basically
helps you to iterate over your list or
any of the collections and most of the
functions for your it labels are inside
enum and some of them could be in lists
or Maps or hash map but enum would be
your most frequently used module and as
you can see in the documentation the
first example itself uses a list the
second example also takes a list and and
simply gives back the sum of the list so
what we can do is let us try and
replicate this functionality by using
our list and recursion
so now let us go back to our code editor
now here let us create a new folder so
inside my directory of flip let us
create a folder by the name of list and
inside this folder let us create a new
file by the name of list dot ex and let
us first Define the module so this has
to be dot tutorials
and this naming conversion doesn't make
any sense so right now let me just take
out this list and let us name the module
as tutorials dot list so let me Define a
function called as sum and this is going
to take a list of our numbers now first
let us think of a base case suppose we
get an empty list so at that time we can
simply return back a zero
so let me Define a base case on the top
so I can say Define my sum and let us
pattern match on an empty list so we can
just write empties right over here so in
case we get an empty list we simply want
to return back a zero so now let us see
how we can write the recursive case now
what we can do is this parameter of
numbers this is actually a list so we
can pattern match right over here so
what I can do is let me take out this
parameter and let us pattern match
inside the function definition let us
collect the head inside a variable
called as H and let us collect the tail
inside a variable called as T now let us
see what we want to do for each
iteration we simply want to add the head
along with the sum and each time we
simply want to pass the tail and that's
it we have a recursive function for
adding all of the elements inside the
list now as you can see that this is not
a tail recursive version so what we can
do is let us try and rename this file so
instead of calling this as sum let us
rename this function from sum to some
simple and here what we can do is since
this is just one single line of return
let me take it to a single line let me
put the codes and we don't need the end
block and let us open up our terminal
and see if this is working or not so let
me go inside my IEX and let me clear up
my terminal and here we can say that
from the model of tutorials I want to go
to the model of list then I want to
invoke the function of some simple and
let us pass the list of 1 2 and 3 and as
expected we get back the answer as 6.
now what we can do is we can also write
this function by using tail recursion so
let us see how we can create the tail
recursive function so we can call that
function as sum and tail recursive and
let us think of different parameters
that we can pass for our tail recursive
version this function will accept two
parameters the first is obviously our
list of numbers and we also need an
accumulator and what we can do is let us
Define the function definition right
over here so we can say that the default
value for our accumulator has to be zero
and now since we have just created the
function definition or the function
header we don't need to create a body
for this one next let us write the
actual implementation so let me just
copy and paste so here we don't need the
default argument and first let us think
of the base case so in case the numbers
is just an empty list so at that time we
simply want to return back our
accumulator the next is our recursive
case so let me again copy and paste now
this time again we can pattern match on
the head and on the tail so we can say
that we want to collect the head and we
also want to collect the tail and for
each iteration we simply want to call
the same function back but now for each
iteration we simply want to pass the
tail we don't need to pass the head for
each iteration and our accumulator
becomes our accumulator plus of our head
and that's it we have a tail recursive
function as well now let us do one
simple thing let me go at the top and
here let me create a function which is
called as sum and this accepts our
numbers and here let us simply call the
tail recursive version so we can say
that I want to call my real recursive
version and let me pass numbers to it so
now we have a much smaller name and this
makes our life much more easy
so let us go back to our terminal let us
recompile tutorials dot list let me
clear up the screen and let us invoke
the same function but this time the name
of the function is just sum and as
expected we get back in the answer as 6
and this time for calculating the sum we
are using the tail recursive version now
going forward I am not going to draw the
recursive trees but if you are not
feeling confident or if you are feeling
confused then I highly motivate you to
draw the recursive trees
now before ending this video I wanted to
show you a couple of things the first
thing is let us see how we can document
all of our code the first thing is we
can use something which is called as
module attributes so on the top we can
say that we want to create documentation
for the entire module so let's document
what we are going to do for this model
of list we are going to implement a
couple of functions that can be used on
the list so I can create a heading for
our function summary and the first one
that we have implemented is for our sum
so this is how you write the module
level documentation next let me show you
how we can write the documentation for
our function so for this we can use the
model attribute of just Doc and inside
the quotation marks let us write the
documentation
saying that this function Returns the
sum of the numbers inside a list so now
if you hover over the definition of sum
we can see that the code editor is
showing us the documentation and the
last thing which I wanted to show you in
this video is how we can Define the type
specifications or the type hints so here
we can use another module attribute by
the name of spec so this stands for the
function specifications so here we want
to define the specifications for our
function of sums and here we can Define
the type of this parameter so in our
case sums is actually a list and the
list contains different numbers so this
is how we can Define the type of numbers
the next comes the return type so here
we can put double quotes and we can say
that the return type is also going to be
a number so what we have done is we have
also added the documentation and we have
also add the specifications so in the
future whenever we you are using tools
like dialyzer it will help you to catch
bugs inside your code next let us write
the specifications for our other
functions as well so let me copy this
one and let me paste it right over here
this function is going to be our sum of
simple next let us also write the
specification for our tail recursive
function so here I can say that this
function name is actually my sum of tail
recursive now this function accepts two
parameter the first parameter is a list
of numbers the second one is simply an
integer so we can say that the second
parameter is an integer and the return
type is number and if you want to read
more about the type specifications then
we can go to the official documentation
and we can go to the tab of pages and
here we can see that we have the
documentation for our type
specifications right now don't worry too
much about type specifications I will
show you how we can write the
specifications for from here on well
that brings us to the end of this video
and I will catch you in the next one
now let us see how we can reverse a list
inside Elixir so for example we have a
list and this list has two elements two
and three so this list would look
something like this inside your memory
so we have two nodes so this node is for
two and this node is for three now here
goes my question suppose we have two
more nodes on the left here we can see
that we have one node and on the right
here we can see that we have one more
node so now the question is would adding
this node to our list of 2 and 3 would
be faster or adding 4 to our list of 2
and 3 would be faster so what do you
think this operation would be faster or
this operation would be faster so the
answer is adding this node would be
faster and this happens in constant time
and the reason is we don't have to
Traverse throughout this entire list we
simply take a node and we simply point
the tail to an existing list and that's
it but what happens if we want to add a
node at the last at that time it is not
efficient because it is going to take a
linear time and adding this node x a
linear time because we have to Traverse
through the entire linked list so in
this case we have to go from this node
to this node and after that we can point
the tail of this node to our last node
so it takes linear time so just keep
this thing in mind that adding a node to
the head would be always faster and
adding a node at the last would take
linear time with this logic in place let
us see how we can reverse a list so for
example we have a list right over here
and we have elements of one two and
three so at that time we will take one
more accumulator list and for each
iteration we will take the head of this
one and we will insert that head inside
our accumulator list so what happens for
the first iteration is we simply take
out the head and we insert the head
inside our accumulator now here since we
are inserting at the head this operation
takes constant time and for the next
iteration what happens since we have
taken out 1 your list now becomes 2 and
3. so for the next iteration we simply
take out 2 and we added 2 to the head of
our existing list now again since we are
adding to the Head this operation also
happens in linear time now going to our
original list since we have taken out 2
we have just one element left and the
same thing happens we simply take the
three out and we add 3 to the head of
our accumulator list and that's it we
have reversed a linked list or rather we
have simply reversed a list inside
Elixir so let us write the code for this
one and let us see these things in
action so here let me put up a command
this is going to be our function of
reverse here let us Define a function
called as reverse now this function
accepts two parameters the first one is
for our elements the second one is for
the accumulator and let us Define the
function signature right over here so in
case the accumulator is not given at
that time we simply want to set the
accumulator to be a blank list the next
comes our base case so let me copy and
paste and here we can pattern match and
we can say that in case we have a blank
list right over here at that time we
simply want to return back our
accumulator so here I can say do and my
accumulator the next comes our recursive
case so again let me copy and paste now
here what we can do is we can simply
pattern match for the list so we can
take the head and we can also take the
tail and for each iteration we have to
call the same function back now let us
see how we can pass the arguments for
our tail recursive function first let us
write the r argument for our accumulator
so if we go back to our diagram so here
what we want to do is we want to take
the head and we want to insert the head
inside our accumulator
so that's what we can do over here so we
simply won't take the head and we want
to add the head to our accumulator now
let us again go back to the diagram now
since we have taken out one our list for
the next iteration should be 2 and 3 and
we can very easily do that
so for the next iteration we simply have
to pass the tail back and that's it we
have a very nice pale recursive program
to reverse our list so let us try this
program inside our IEX so let me open up
my terminal let me go inside my IEX
now here let me clear up my screen and I
can say that I want to go from my model
of tutorials to my list and I want to
reverse and let us pass the argument of
one two and three and as expected we get
back the answer as 3 2 and 1. now the
last thing inside this video is let us
also write the specifications for this
function here we can use the module
attribute for our specifications and we
can say that our function of reverse now
here we can say that elements is
actually going to be a list and since we
don't know what type of elements would
be there inside the list we can say that
they can be of any type and the same
thing goes for our accumulator as well
here let me show you one more alternate
syntax so instead of writing list we can
simply write a list like this and inside
the list we can specify that this list
can hold any kind of elements and again
for the return type we can say that the
return type is also list and this list
can hold anything so we can specify any
right over here and just for the sake of
consistency let me convert this as well
so let me put square brackets we don't
need this and that's it for this video
I'll catch you in the next one
next let us see how we can implement the
map function but first let me show you
what do I mean to say
so here let us see the documentation so
I want to go to my model of enum and I
want to see the documentation of map
so as you can see over here so this map
function this takes a list of elements
and it also takes a function and what
does it do for each iteration it simply
applies this function to the element so
for example we can see that the first
element is 1 and this function is taking
one and it is giving back 1 multiplied
by two that's why we have the answer of
2 over here now we move to the next
element the next element is 2 so 2
multiplied by 2 we get a 4 the next one
is three three multiplied by 2 so we get
a 6 right over here and we have one more
example right over here so in this case
this is a keyword list and what this
function is doing it is pattern matching
on the key envelope Paris and it is
simply changing the value from a
positive to a negative number so for the
first iteration your key is the item of
a and the value is is 1 and what this
function is doing it is returning back a
negative value so we have minus 1 right
over here for the next iteration the key
is the item of B and the value is 2 and
here we are simply flipping the sign so
that's why we get minus 2 right over
here so let us see how we can implement
this function by using our list so let
us go back to our code editor and here
let us create a new function called as
map and let us see how we can implement
this functionality so this function is
going to accept three parameters the
first is for our elements the second one
is for the function and the third one is
obviously our accumulator and also let
us set the accumulator to be a blank
list
now before we can go ahead I wanted to
show you one more thing all of these
functions that we are defining inside
the module so this function of sum of
some simple sum of tail recursive
reverse all of these functions are
called as named functions and they're
called name functions because all of
these functions belong to a module and
in our case the model is called as
tutorials.list but in case for this
function of map we are passing an
anonymous function so this function does
not belong to any module so let us see
how we can work with our Anonymous
functions as well so what we can do is
either we can create an anonymous
function right where we require or we
can Define it separately as well so
suppose we Define a function called as
double and we can say that this is going
to be a Anonymous function and this
function accepts some element and it
simply returns that element multiplied
by 2
now remember the syntax the opening is
by FN that stands for your function the
end happens with your end block right
over here now in order to use this
function we have to use a DOT notation
so in order to invoke this function we
can say that we want to invoke the
anonymous function of double but if we
want to pass the value of 2 and as you
can see we have to use the dot notation
since this is an anonymous function so
keeping this thing in mind let us go
back to our code editor so let me scroll
down to our functional definition and
here it is so as usual first let us
think about the base case so let me just
copy and paste so the base case would be
in case the elements are blank that
means it's just a blank list at that
time we simply want to return back the
accumulator so we can say do and our
accumulator now here what happens is we
don't need this argument and we can do
one more thing since we are not using
the function we can ignore it by using
an underscore so what this underscore
means is we simply want to ignore the
value of function in our base case next
let us have a look at our recursive case
so let me again copy and paste here as
usual let me pattern match on our head
and our tail the next is our function
and since this is a tail recursive
function we have to call ourselves back
each time so first let me ignore the
first value I will come to this a little
later now the next argument is for the
function in and for each iteration we
simply have to pass the function as it
is we don't have to do anything with it
now the third is where we collect our
accumulator now inside the accumulator
what do we want to do is we simply want
to take this function and we want to
apply this function on our head now
remember that since this is an anonymous
function we can use the dot syntax so we
can say here first we want to take the
function and use the dots and tags and
we want to apply this function on our
head and we simply want to append our
accumulator at the back now let us come
to the first argument now since we have
used the head the only thing left is to
pass the pail and that's it let me save
the file and let us open up our IEX let
us go inside our IX and let me clear up
everything and let us try it out so we
can see tutorials dot list dot map and
we can say that our map is 1 2 and 3 and
the function that phone to pass is the
same one let us take the element and for
each element let us simply multiply by 2
don't forget the end and that's it and
we get the answer back but as you can
see the order is not right what has
happened is we have reverse the list as
well so this 3 is right over here so 3
multiplied by 2 it should be 6 but in
our case 6 is the first element and 2
into 2 we have 4 over here and for the
first element is one into two and we
have 2 right over here but as you can
see that this is not the right answer we
have reversed the order of our elements
as well so what we can do is first we
can call our tutorials.list DOT reverse
and inside this let us pass our map
function let me just copy and paste it
over here and now we can see that we
have the right answer 2 4 and 6 but as
you can see that this syntax can be
confusing so let me introduce shows you
the pipeline operator so let us paste
the map function over here and we can
see that we simply want to take the
output of this map function and we want
to pipe that output inside the new
function and the new function is our
tutorials dot list dot reverse now here
we don't need to specify the arguments
what happens is the pipeline operator
since it takes the output of the
previous statement and it simply passes
that output inside our function as the
first argument so let us press enter and
let us see what's happening so as
expected we get the right answer back 2
4 and 6. let me clear it up let us do
some more so for example if you want to
reverse the same list so we can invoke
tutorials.list dot reverse and suppose
in our case the list is one two three
and four now instead of using this
syntax what we can do is we can first
take our our elements here we can use
the pipe operator so we can say that I
want you to take all of these elements
and I want you to pass them to my
tutorials dot list dot reverse so what
happens is we can use this pipeline
operator in case if we have multiple
Transformations so let us use the same
example one more time here let us create
an anonymous function called as double
and what we want to do is we simply want
to take the element and we want to
return that element multiplied by 2 and
now let us see how we can use the
pipeline operator so for example we have
a list like this one two three and four
and what we can do is we can take this
elements and we can pipe this elements
to our function of tutorials dot list
dot map now remember that the function
of map accepts two parameters elements
and the function now here what happens
is since we are using the pipeline
operator this elements are passed
automatically to the function of map and
the pipeline operator always passes
these elements as the first argument so
since we have the first argument we
simply have to pass the second argument
so here we can say that we want to pass
the anonymous function called as double
and for the accumulator we don't have to
pass any value because the default value
for the accumulator is an empty list so
let us see the output of this one so we
get the output of 8 6 4 and 2. now what
we can do is we can take the exact same
expression and we can find the output of
the map function to our reverse function
so we can use
tutorials.list dot reverse and this time
we get the expected answer as 2 4 6 and
8. now instead of using the list dot
reverse in fact we can use the inbuilt
module so if we go to the model of enum
so here we can say that we want to pipe
the output into enum Dot reverse and we
get the exact same answer back so
instead of using our defined function we
can use the inbuilt function as well so
as you can see that this pipeline
operator is very handy whenever we want
to do multiple Transformations so let us
go back to our function of map and what
we want to do is this accumulator has to
be piped to our function of reverse and
that's it now if we open up our terminal
let us recompile
tutorials.list let us clear up
everything and this time if I have a
list of one two three and four and if I
just type this list to tutorials.list
dot map and let us pass an anonymous
function so we can say let us take that
element and let us multiply that element
by 3 this time and that's it we get the
right output back now again coming back
to our code editor either you can use
this pipeline operator or you can use
the conversion syntax so you can simply
call the function of remote first pass
the element of accumulator and let me
take out this one let us also see how to
write the specifications for this
function so let us use the model
attribute of specifications for the
function of map now the first parameter
elements is going to be a list and the
type can be of anything so anything goes
over here the next is a function now in
order to denote that this is a function
we can use brackets over here and here
we can say that this function accepts an
input the input can be of any type then
it transforms that value and it also
gives back some kind of a value back so
this is how we can Define the function
type the next one is for the accumulator
and again accumulator is going to be a
list of any now the return type is also
going to be our list of any well that's
it for this one and I will catch you in
the next video now let us see how we can
concat or how we can add two lists
together the
so first let me show you inside the
terminal so suppose we have one list
like this one two and three and we want
to add one more list now in order to add
our concat we have to use the double
plus and the next list would be 4 5 and
6.
and here we get the combined list back
so let us see how we can write a concat
function to do exactly this now in order
to add or concat we have two lists so
for example the first list is one two
and three and we have one more list four
five and six so essentially what we want
to do is we want to take the last
element and we want to insert that last
element at the head of the next list but
taking the last element is not efficient
because we have to Traverse through the
entire list and then go to the last
element so what we can do is we can
simply reverse the first list so the
first list becomes something like this 3
2 and 1 and for each iteration we simply
have to take out the head and insert it
at the head position for our list number
two as well so for the first iteration
we insert three for the next iteration
we insert two and for the last one we
insert one and and by the time we insert
one this list becomes an empty list so
this is how we are going to implement
our concat function so let's define the
function right over here so we can say
Define concat now this function accepts
two arguments we can call the first list
as our source the second list can be our
destination now for this function we
don't need an accumulator the second
list itself acts like an accumulator so
here what I'm going to do is I am going
to write an auxiliary function so first
let us write the function and then we
can Define it so we can simply call the
auxiliary function as concat underscore
function now remember as I just said a
couple of minutes back first we have to
reverse this list and we can do that
right inside our function definition so
here we can say that let us take the
source list and we simply want to pipe
it to our function of reverse the next
is our destination list and we want our
destination list as it is so now we can
go ahead and Define this auxiliary
function so here we can say that we want
to create a function called as concat
func this accepts two parameter the
first list called as Source the second
list called as destination now here as
our base case we can simply pattern
match on our source so in case the
source is blank at that time we simply
want to return back our destination the
next let us see how we can Define the
recursive case so we can say we want to
Define concat one more time and here we
can simply pattern match on the first
list so for the first list we can
pattern match on the head and for the
tail the second parameter is for our
destination list and let us see how we
can Define the logic for this one now
for each iteration we want to call
ourselves back right here first let us
Define the second parameter so for each
relation what we want to do is we simply
want to take the head and we want to
append our destination list to this one
now the last thing to do is we simply
have to pass the tail for our first
argument so let me open up my terminal
let me go inside my IEX and let me clear
up everything now here we can see that
we want to go to tutorials dot list dot
concat now the first list would be one
two and three the second list would be 4
5 and 6 and that's it we get back in the
desired output the last thing to do is
we simply want to add our type
specification so let me take out the
command I don't need the comment and
here we can use the model attribute of
specifications for our function of
concat the first parameter is a list and
the elements are any the next parameter
is also list and the elements are of any
type and this gives back a list and the
types are any next coming to our helper
function of concat underscore func now
this function is intended only for
internal use so what we can do is we can
Define the auxiliary function to be
private so here instead of just writing
def we can write Def and P that means
that this is going to be a private
function and that's it let's have a look
at the last function inside our list and
this function is called as flat map now
to be frank I was slightly confused
should I include this function in this
series or not then I thought okay why
not let me add this one and let us see
how it goes so first let me show you
what do I mean by a flat map so let us
go back to our terminal and here let us
see the documentation for our inner
module and the flat map function so what
this function does is it accepts an enum
and it also accepts one function now
flat map is all about the combination of
your two functions that is it's a
combination of your map and concat and
here we have one more example as well so
we get an input as a list so during the
first iteration we get an item of a and
we give back list of a and a but if you
see right over here we don't have a list
of a we don't have a separate list for B
and we don't have a separate list of c
and that's because we have flat and the
entire list so let us see how we can do
this by using our recursive functions
now you must be thinking why are we
implementing so many functions which are
already there inside the standard
Library so the answer is I want you to
really get comfortable with the
recursion and from the next video we
will see how we can use all of the
inbuilt modules but for this last one
let us see how we can implement this
functionality by using our tail
recursive function so let us go back to
our code editor and here let us create a
function called as flat map so we can
say Define my flat map so this function
accepts two parameters so if you go back
to the documentation we can see that
this accepts two parameters the first
argument is for the elements the second
argument is for the function so let us
do the same thing here we can say that
the first argument is for the elements
the second argument is for a function
now we also need one more argument for
our accumulator
because what we want to do is we want to
collect the output inside our
accumulator
so here we can say that we also want to
have an accumulator and we want to have
the default value of an empty list as
well now let me copy and paste now let
us think of our base case so the base
case is very simple in case the elements
is a bank list at that time we don't
need this function so either you can put
an underscore over here or you can
simply replace the entire function with
just an underscore both of them are
valid syntax and in this case we simply
want to return back the accumulator as
it is now let us copy and paste one more
time and this is going to be our
recursive case now in this case we need
our function as well and for the first
argument let us pattern match on our
head and our tail and for each iteration
we want to call ourselves back so let us
call the flat map back now as you know
the first argument should be our tail
because for each iteration we want to
take out the head so the first argument
becomes the tail the second argument is
we want to pass the function as it is we
don't want to change the function now
let us see what we can pass as our third
argument now if you go back to our
documentation it is clearly saying that
this is a combination of our map and
concat so let's not use our brain and
let's follow exactly what these guys are
seeing
so here what we want to do is we simply
want to concat and the first argument
for our contact function is going to be
our accumulator and for the second
function we want to apply this Anonymous
function on the head now remember since
function is an anonymous function we can
invoke it by using the dot operator so
we can say function Dot and let us pass
head to this one and that's it we have
implemented the flat map function now
let me open up my terminal let us
recompile the model of tutorials dot
list let me clear up the screen and
let's do one thing let us go over here
and let me copy all of these things
now here inside our terminal we can say
that from tutorials dot list dot flat
map and it has passed arguments and now
let us try and compare the output so
here we have the output which is exactly
the same as right over here so that
brings us to the end of this section for
the list now what we have done for this
section is we have implemented a lot of
functions from the standard Library by
using field recursion from the next
video instead of writing all of these
functions by hand we will try and use
the functions from the standard library
but for now that's it and I will catch
you in the next one hi and
congratulations for making it so far so
till now we have seen a lot of recursion
specifically we have seen a lot of tail
regression now the whole idea of showing
you so much of Education was I wanted
you to get used to the idea of recursion
and how we can use functional
programming but moving forward instead
of writing all of the functions
ourselves we will use the functions from
the standard library now Alexa ships
with a lot of inbuilt functions and you
can find these functions inside modules
such as enum then we have separate model
for your list and keyword list and so on
so that's what we will see so the next
section is all about your data
Transformations how we can use all of
these functions and how we can browse
some data to get our desired outputs so
I will catch you right in the next video
till then bye now let us see how we can
start working with our struts and the
inbuilt modules so the first thing which
I want to do is let us create a new
folder inside our lib and we can call
that folder as structs and inside of
this folder let me create one more file
by the name of Seven Wonders let me
collapse my sidebar and let us see what
we can do with this struct the first
thing as usual we need to Define our
module so this would be our tutorials
Dot
structs.7 vendors so let us create a
struct by using the keyword of Dev
struct here we need to specify the
fields for our struct so we can say that
the first field would be the name of the
Seven Wonders and the second field would
be the country of that seven Wonder now
we can do one slight Improvement we can
also initialize the values right over
here and instead of just passing a
normal list we can pass a keyword list
so here we can say that the default
value of name should be a blank string
and the same thing happens for the
country as well so in case the argument
is not given we want to initialize the
country to be a blank string now let us
see how we can also Define the type
specifications for our struct now for
defining the type of our struct we have
to use the keyword of type so let's
define a typewrite over here and let us
call type as T so this is more like your
community attention your T stands just
for your type and here we can specify
that we want to specify that 5 for our
tutorials dot structs dot Seven Wonders
now remember that this track always
takes the name of the module and in this
case the name of our module is
tutorials.structs.7 vendors so by
default that's going to be the name of
our struct and since this is a struct
let us use the right syntax so we need
to put our percent symbol over here and
our curly brackets so now we have a
struct now what we can do is typing such
a long name can be boring so we can
simply Alias this so let's create an
alias at the top so we can say we simply
want to create an alias and here we can
simply take out all of these things now
inside the curly brackets let us Define
the pipes for the various Fields so the
first field inside our struct of 7
Wonders is for the name and here we can
Define the type to be of string so we
can say string dot P so the type of
string the next one we have for the
country and again the country is going
to be of the type of string so this is
how you define the type specifications
for your struct next let us do one more
thing Let Us create a list of all of the
seven vendors so for this let us create
a simple function called let's all so
this function does not take anything and
this returns your list now inside this
list let us initialize all of the Seven
Wonders so we can say that the first
seven Wonder would be Taj Mahal so since
I am from India the first one has to be
Taj Mahal and we can say the country is
going to be India and let me just copy
and paste all of the remaining six
wonders so now we have a nice list of
all of the Seven Wonders of the World
next let us see how we can also write
the type specifications for this new
function so here we can use the model
attribute of our specification things
and we want to define the specifications
for the function of all now since this
function does not accept any parameters
you can use the brackets or you can skip
them and here we can also Define the
return type now the return type is a
list and the elements are of the type of
P so right over here we have defined the
type of T and we have specified the
different parameters for our struct and
that's what we are referencing right
over here let me put a separator line
over here let's scroll a little bit down
and let us see how we can start working
with our Seven Wonders so here let us do
one thing let us Define a function
called as print names so what this
function will do is it will accept all
of the vendors and it will simply print
out the names of the vendors so for
example if we see we have different
names so we have the Taj Mahal Petra
price the Redeemer and so on so what I
want you to do for this function is so
this function is going to accept this
list right over here and for the output
which just want to see the names and
that's it so let us see how we can
implement this function now this time
instead of writing functions of a self
let us see how we can use the standard
Library
so let me open up my terminal and here
the first model that you would like to
check is the model of enum so what I can
do is let us call help and let us see
what are the different functions inside
the module of enum so if I put a dot and
if I press Tab and we can see that this
inbuilt module has a lot of inbuilt
functions now I want to see the
documentation of a very specific
function and that is this one for each
so here let me call the help on enum.h
so this function of each accepts two
parameters the first parameter is for an
enum and the second one is for the
function and we also have a sample
implementation so here we can see that
the first parameter is a list and we
have a simple function so what's
happening is for each iteration this
function receives an element from the
list so for the first iteration your X
is the string of sum and what this
function is doing it is simply printing
it out that's why we have the output of
sum for the second iteration your X
becomes example and that is what is
being printed out right over here so let
us see how we can use this inbuilt
function for printing out all of the
names for our Seven Wonders so let us go
back to our code editor and here what we
can do is we can use the same function
we can say enum dot each now our enum is
going to be our list of our wonders next
let us Define our function and for the
function for each iteration we are going
to receive one Wonder from our list of
vendors so for each iteration what's
going to happen is we are going to
receive a wonder and we have to do
something with the Wonder and this is
the end block for our function now since
we just want to print the name of our
Wonder we can actually pattern match
right over here now we know that this
vendor is going to be thus extract of
Seven Wonders and we can easily patent
match on our structs by using our map
syntax so let's do the pattern match
right over here so here we can say that
for each iteration we want to pattern
match and we want to pattern match on
the parameter of name and we want to
collect the name inside a variable
called as name and for each iteration we
simply want to print it out and let us
put the variable of name right here and
that's it let us open up our terminal
let me go inside my IX now let me create
an alias for our tutorials not structs
DOT 7 vendors let me clear up everything
and here we can say that the list of all
our vendors is our Seven Wonders and
remember we have defined a function of
all so now we have all of the vendors
let me clear up one more time and next
what we can do is we can again use the
same model of seven vendors and let us
print out the names so this function
takes one argument and that is the list
of all our wonders and that's it now we
can see that we have the right output
and we get back just the names of all of
our seven vendors let us go back to the
code editor and let us also Define the
type specification for this function so
here we can say that the specifications
for our function of print names so the
first argument is the list of all of our
vendors so we can say that this is a
list and the type is the type of key
that we have defined now since this
function is not returning anything we
can say that this simply returns an item
of okay also if you want you can also
use the pipeline operator so what I can
do let me take this one out let me put
it on this line and on the next line let
me use the pipeline operator so by
default our list of vendors is being
passed as the first argument for the
function of enum dot each let me save
this one let me open up my terminal let
me again recompile everything let us try
to run the same function one more time
and as expected we get the right answer
back next let us see how we can filter a
single seven vendor from our list so
here let us create a new function and
let me name the function as filter by
country now this function will accept
two parameters the first parameter is
obviously the list of all our vendors
and the second one is the name of our
country for which we want to filter for
so for example if the country is India
then we should get back this single
seven Wonder so let us see how we can
implement this filter function here let
me add my do and end blocks and let me
take this a little up so again let us go
back to our terminal and let us see if
we can find a filter function inside our
standard Library so again let me call
the helper documentation from our model
of enum and let us see if this model has
a function of filter or not so here it
is we have a function of filter so let
us see the documentation of this
function so this function of filter this
accepts two different parameters the
first is obviously our enum and second
parameter is going to be a function and
here we have a sample implementation
so as we can see the first element is a
list and the second argument is going to
be a function now if we read the
documentation it is saying that this
function returns only those elements for
which your function returns a truth
value so let's see what's happening
inside this example so here they have a
condition and whenever this condition
evaluates to True only that value is
returned so here we have a list of 1 2
and 3 and this condition is only
satisfied for the element of 2 and
that's why we get back a list along with
a single element of 2. so let's see how
we can use this inbuilt function for
filtering by the name of our country so
here we can take the list of our vendors
and then we can pipe this argument to
our enum dot filter now again by default
the first argument of Wonders would be
passed and we simply need to pass the
second argument for our function this
function receives a wonderful each
iteration so this is how it's going to
look like and here we need to specify a
condition that will evaluate toward true
so here what we can do is we can again
pattern match on this struct of seven
vendors so let's do that thing and this
time we simply want to extract the name
of the country so let us pattern match
on the field of country and let us
collect the data inside a variable
called as country name now next coming
to our truth condition here we can say
that we want to filter it out only when
the country name is equal to the name of
the country so this parameter country is
what is being passed to our function
right over here and this parameter of
country name is what we are extracting
by using our pattern match right over
here so let me save the file let us open
up our terminal and let us recompile the
model of Seven Wonders
next what we can do is we can say we
want to use Seven Wonders dot filter by
country let us pass all of the Wonders
and next let us pass India and let us
see what output we are getting and as
expected we can see that we are getting
the right answer back let us try one
more time and let us try with Mexico and
again we are getting the right answer
back so again let us go back right over
here and let us write the type
specifications so the specifications for
our filter by country the first argument
is the list of the type of seven vendors
the second argument is of the type of
string and the return type is the list
and this contains a single type well
that's it for this video in the next
video we will continue with the
different functions on our structs so
let us continue with our structs and
behind the scenes what I've done is I
have added a couple of functions and let
us see how we can Implement all of these
functions
so the first function that you can see
over here so this function is also about
filtering and we simply want to filter
out the seven wonders for which the
countries start with I so let us see how
we can do this one let me copy this one
and let me paste it right over here let
me take all of these things a little up
so in this case our truth function will
change and we simply want to compare the
values and check if the name of the
country starts with I or not so let me
take this one out and this time we can
rename the variable from country name to
just country and let us see how we can
compare the first alphabet of our string
with i for this let us use another
module and the name of the module is
going to be string and this model has a
very convenient function of starts with
now if I hover over the function
definition we can see that this function
accepts two different parameters so they
have one example over here Alexa and Eli
so in this case Elixir starts with Eli
that's why we get the answer as true so
the first argument would be our country
and the second argument would be I so
let me open up the terminal again let me
recompile our model of Seven Wonders let
me clear up everything now let's invoke
the function so we can say Seven Wonders
dot countries which start with i and let
us pass all of the Wonders to this one
and as expected we get two wonders back
so the first one is Made in India the
second one is made in Italy the next
function is sort by country length oh
before moving on let us also add in the
type specifications for this one so the
specifications are pretty simple
this one does is the list of our type of
T and this also returns a list of type
of T all right so now let us go to this
sort function so this time what we want
to do is we simply want to sort all of
the Wonders by the length of the country
name so let us see how we can do this
one so if I go back to my terminal and
let's check out for enum dot sort so we
have a convenient function of sort
inside the model of enum and as you can
see it has a lot of documentation but I
wanted to show you a couple of key
parameters so this is the function of
sort and this function accepts to
parameter the first is the enum and the
second one is unsorter now this sorter
argument can be of multiple types so let
us refer to the official specifications
for this function and let us try and
figure it out so the first is obviously
your elements and now for the second
argument of sort we can see that we can
pass a multiple of arguments so what
this specification is saying that either
we can pass a function and this function
receives two elements and this function
has to written back a Boolean value or
you can choose to pass this arguments as
well now let us see how we can work with
this one so this is a pretty simple
function that we can pass to our enum
dot sort so let us go back to our code
editor
let us again use the arguments of Wonder
and let us pipe this one to our enum dot
sort now here let us see how we can
Define the sorter function so this is
going to be your regular function now
for each iteration this function is
going to receive two different vendors
so we can call them as X and Y and next
for the body of the function we can
simply say that we want to check for the
length of the string for the first one
and let's compare if this length is less
than the length of the next Wonder so
again we can use the same function
string dot length and let us pass the
variable of Y this time so what we have
done is we have defined a function and
for each iteration this function
receives two different vendors and we
are simply trying to compare the length
of this wonders and that's it so let me
save the file let me open up my terminal
and let me again recompile the module
let's try to Inver this function Seven
Wonders dot sort by country length and
let us pass all of our vendors
oh we are getting an error and that's
because here we are trying to find the
length of the entire struct I forgot to
specify the parameter that we want to
check for the length of the name of the
country the same thing goes for this
struct as well so we want to check for
the length of this country now let me
save the file open up my terminal let me
recompile one more time clear up the
screen and let us try to invoke this
function one more time so this time as
you can see we have a nice sorted list
so as you can see now the list is sorted
according to the length of the country
name so Peru this is four characters
long so this is the first one next is
China this is five characters again then
we have Italy and India then we have
Brazil and so on so as you can see we
have a nicely sorted list so now let us
go back and let us see what we want to
do for the next one so for the next
function of name country list so this
function accepts our vendors and I want
an output like this so the output has to
be the list and inside the list we want
another list the first element has to be
the name of the seven wonder and the
second name has to be the country so let
us see how we can do this one so let me
take out the comment I don't need the
comments and before I show this one let
me take you back to my terminal and let
me clear up all of these things
and this time let us check out the
documentation for enum dot reduce now
this function of reduce this is a very
powerful function and in fact you can
Implement all of the function inside the
model of enum by just using this simple
function so first let us see the
function signature so this function of
reduce accepts three parameters the
first argument is for your enum the
second argument is for accumulator and
the third argument is for your function
and we have one sample example right
over here so the first argument is a
list the second argument is for the
accumulator and the third argument that
you can see over here this is for a
function now this function receives an
element for each iteration and this
function also receives the accumulator
so for the first iteration since the
accumulator is 0 this would be 0 and for
the first iteration our X would be 1.
now what happens with this function is
that the result is passed as the
accumulator for the next iteration
so you can read the documentation over
here so this is what is happening so for
the second iteration whatever this
evaluates to so this value will become
your new accumulator so let us see this
reduce function in action so let us go
back to our code editor now let us see
how we can work with our reduce function
so we can say enum dot reduce the first
argument is for our vendors the second
argument is going to be our accumulator
so as our initial accumulator let us
just pass an empty list and the third
one is going to be a function now let me
do one thing let me take this one out
and let us pipe into our enum dot reduce
now for each iteration this function is
going to receive two parameters the
first parameter is going to be our
vendor and the second parameter is going
to be our accumulator so initially the
accumulator is going to be a blank list
and for each iteration what we want to
do we simply want to create a list
inside this list we need another list
and inside this inner list the first
argument would be the name of the vendor
and second one would be the country of
the Wonder so here we can say that from
Wonder I simply want you to take the
name and the second argument is going to
be the country for this one and after
this we simply want to append our
accumulator back and that's it let me
save my file let me open up my terminal
let me recompile the module and let me
clear up the screen let us invoke this
function so we can say Seven Wonders dot
name country list and let us pass all of
the Wonders and as expected we get the
answer back so here we can see the first
argument is going to be the name of the
Wonder followed by the name of the
country now just to give you some more
practice let us try and use this reduce
function one more time so for this
function right we are country name
keyword list so this is what I want you
to do so this function is going to
accept our vendors and this is the
output that I'm expecting so we want to
have a list and inside the list we want
to create our keyword list so as you can
see this is going to be an atom and this
is going to be the value so let me just
copy all of these things let me copy
this one and let me paste it right over
here I don't need the comment let me
take it out and let us see how we can
work with this function now here what I
want to do is we don't want an inner
list instead what we want is a tuple so
let me change this from a list to a
tuple so let me explain why do I want a
tuple so let me open up my terminal so
for example if we have a keyword list
like this a and one so this keyword list
is actually saved as a list of our
tuples so in case if I have to pattern
match so on the left hand side let us
create one more list and here if I
create a tuple the first element is
going to be the item of a the second
element is going to be the value of 1.
so let us see if this is a pattern match
or not so yes this is a pattern match so
what's happening is this keyword list is
saved in this format I think I have
covered this while explaining keyword
list as well so this is a small recap
for you so this is the same logic that
we are using over here so that's why we
want to have a tuple and not an inner
list now the first element has to be an
atom so what I can do is let me grab
this inside and we can convert this
string to an atom by using our string
dot to atom and that's it now let me
open up my terminal again let us
recompile our module and let me clear up
the screen and let us try to invoke this
functions Seven Wonders dot country name
keyword list and let us pass the
arguments of all vendors so the system
as you can see that the first argument
is going to be our atom and the value is
going to be the name of the country now
before going to the last function I
wanted to show you a couple of things so
again let me open up my terminal
let me clear up all of those things so
in case if you want to make a list of
just the names of the Wonders we can use
multiple modules so let me show you one
more alternate method so we can say enum
dot map and the first argument is going
to be our argument of all of our vendors
and what we can do is we can simply
invoke a function so this function
receives a Wonder each time and what we
want to do is we simply want to return
the name of the Wonder and we get back a
list of all of the names now what we can
do is Alexa actually offers a shorthand
syntax so what we can do is we can
change this function to a short and
syntax so we can say that we want to
send a reference to an anonymous
function and this function is going to
receive a parameter so we can say for
the first parameter we simply want to
return the name back and that's it so
this is the shorthand syntax and we get
the exact same answer attack so if you
are comfortable you can use the short
and syntax or else you can use the
regular syntax now for the last part of
this video I wanted to show you the four
comprehensions inside Elixir we can get
the exact same output by using the four
comprehensions so we can say four and
here we can say that for each iteration
we simply want to pattern match and we
want to extract the name inside the
variable of name and we want to extract
this from our list of all of the vendors
and for each iteration I simply want to
return back the name of the Wonder and
that's it we get back the exact same
result now this syntax is slightly weird
so what we are trying to do is we are
trying to say that for each element out
of this enum we want to pattern match
and we want to pattern match on name and
for each iteration we simply want to
return the name back so you can use any
of the syntax with which you feel more
comfortable now let me just copy this
one and let me go back to my code editor
so for this one let us use the for
comprehension let me paste it right over
here we also need to pass an argument to
the function so this argument becomes
for our vendors and this also has to
change to wonders now let me open up my
terminal let me recompile the module and
let me clear up this one and let us try
to run this one so Seven Wonders dot all
names oh I forgot to pass the arguments
so all names and the argument is all
wonders and we get back the exact same
answer well that's it for this video and
I will catch you in the next one
let us have some more practice with our
struts so what I've done is behind the
scenes I've created a new file called as
expense and let us get started with this
one so first as usual let us create our
module and let me call this module as
tutorials.structs dot expense
now just imagine that we are creating an
application to manage our expenses so
let us Define a struct to hold our
expenses so we can say that we want to
define a struct and since this struct is
going to have multiple Fields let me
take them on different lines so the
first field would be for the title of
our expense and we can initialize the
title to be a blank string the second
one would be the date of our expense
initially we can keep it as nil the next
one would be the amount of our expense
and let us initialize the amount to be 0
the next one can be the store from which
we did the purchase and let us
initialize the store to be also a blank
string now let us also Define the types
for our struct so first let me create an
alias so I want to create an alias for
my tutorials dot structs dot expense and
here let us Define the type for this one
so we can say that type of t for our
struct of our expense
the first field for title so this is
going to be of the type of string the
second one is date for this we can
specify that the type is going to be of
the type of date or it can also be nil
the next one is for our amount so this
is going to be a number and next one is
for the store this is going to be of the
type of string
so now we have the type specification in
place
now let us see how we can work with our
expense struct first let me create a
couple of sample expenses so let me
Define so let me Define a function
called as sample so this function will
simply return a couple of our expenses
let us create an expense right over here
so we can say that we want to create an
expense now for the title we can say
that we got some grocery
the next field is for the date now the
type of this has to be a date so for
this let me go to my terminal and here
let me show you how we can create a date
so Elixir has a model for date so we can
use that module so let me show you so
let us check the documentation for that
module so we can say we want to see the
helper documentation of date dot new
so as you can see this function of new
this accepts a year month and day so let
us try this one
so let me clear up everything so here we
can create a new date so we can say date
dot new the first argument was for the
year so we can say 2023 the next
argument was for the month so we can say
for April and for the day we can say the
1st of April
and that's it we get back a date but as
you can see we get back a couple back so
let us pattern match and let us extract
the date so what we can do is just on
the left hand side let me pattern match
so the first element would be the item
of okay and let us create a variable for
the date
and let us just check out the contents
update
so that's it we have a new date
now the syntax that you can see over
here this Sigel and D this also denotes
a date and in fact we can use this
syntax to create a new date we don't
have to always invoke the function of
date dot new so what we can do is we can
create a Sigil so this is the sign for
sigil and let us create a schedule for
our date and here we can say that the
year has to be 2023 the month can be
March and the date can be 31st of March
and that's it we have a new date in
place so now let us go back to the
struct and let us create a date right
over here so let me use the sigil over
here so I can say I want to create a
date and suppose my year is 2023 my
month can be September and suppose the
date is 12th of September next is the
amount suppose the amount is 18.99 and
let's say the store is going to be
Metro so now we have created an expense
now let me just copy and paste a bunch
of more expenses so that's it let me
open up my terminal and let me clear up
all of these things let us go inside the
IEX and let me create an alias for of my
tutorials dot structs dot expense and
let me clear this one more time let us
create a variable for our sample
expenses so we can say that my sample
expenses is equal to my expenses dot the
function of sample so now we have a
bunch of samples so now let us go back
to the code editor and let us see what
we can do with our expenses oh before
that let us add the type specifications
for this one so here we can specify that
the specifications for our sample so
this does not accept anything and this
returns a list of the type of T that we
have just defined next let us write a
function to get the total amount that we
have spent so we can say that the
function is going to be our total and
this function accepts our expenses and
let's define the body of this function
so this expenses would be the list of
all our expenses for example if we get
this expenses then we simply want to add
all of the amounts together and we want
to give back the total amount so let us
see how we can do this one let me take
all of these things a little up now you
can solve this by using multiple methods
but I'm going to use the enum dot reduce
so first let me take the expenses and
let me pipe the expenses into enum dot
reduce now for this function of reduce
let us Define an accumulator so let's
say that my initial accumulator is 0 the
next one comes the function now for each
iteration this function receives two
parameter the first is going to be the
expense the second is going to be the
accumulator and for each iteration I
simply want to go to my expense take the
amount and add add that amount to my
accumulator so that's it now let us go
back to our terminal let us recompile
our expense let me clear up everything
and now let us invoke this function so
we can say expense dot let us get the
total for our sample and that's it we
get the answer as
1025.62 let us go back and let us also
write the type specifications for this
one so this function of total this
accepts a list of the type of T and this
returns a number so if you hover our
number you can see that your number can
either be an integer or a float next let
us write a function to sort our expenses
by the date so we can say that we want
to define a function and this function
accepts our list of expenses and now let
us see how we can sort our list so in
the last video we have seen how to sort
a list but this time we want to sort by
date so let me take you back to my
terminal so let us see the documentation
for our enum dot sort so last time we
had used sort but we have one more
function by the name of salt and buy now
let us see the documentation for this
one let me slightly scroll up and here
they have an example in which they are
using date so for example they have a
list of different maps and each of the
map has a field for the date and this is
how they are sorting the date so the
first argument is obviously your enum
for the second argument they are using a
shortened syntax you can use your
regular function and what they are
trying to say is for each iteration they
want to sort by the birthday so let us
use this shorthand syntax and let us see
how we can sort our date
so here we can say that first let me
take all of my expenses then let me pipe
all of these things into my enum dot
sort by and let us use the shorthand
syntax so we can say I want to give a
reference to an anonymous function and
for each iteration I want to sort by the
date let us open up our terminal let us
recompile our expense let me clear out
the screen and here we can say dot
expense dot sort by date and let us pass
the list of our samples and let us see
what's happening so here you can see
that the dates are sorted the last one
is for 30th of October the earlier one
is 18th of October so this one is for
September and this one is for July so we
have a nicely sorted list in ascending
order in case if you want to change the
order you can refer the documentation so
yeah they are saying that in case if you
want descending then you can add this
parameters as well let us go back let us
write this specifications for this one
so sort by date so this accepts the list
of the type of p and this also Returns
the same list of the type of t next let
us see how we can add an expense to our
list of expenses so let's define a
function called as ADD expense so this
accepts one single expense and let us
write the body of our function
now this is going to be a very simple
function so we simply have to take the
expense and we simply want to append
this expense to our existing list of
samples now for this one I wanted to
show you one small trick so in case if
you want to enforce that this expense
has to be of the type of the struct of
expense then what we can do is we can
simply use a pattern match right over
here so here we can say that we want to
have a pattern match for our struct of
expense so essentially what we are doing
is we want to enforce that the type of
this parameter has to be of the type of
our struct let us also add the
specifications for this one so we can
say that our ad expense this accepts the
type of T and this Returns the list and
the list has of the type of t as well
now let me open up my terminal let us
also recompile the model for our expense
let me clear up everything now first let
me create an expense so let us create a
variable for our expense and let us
initialize our struct so here we want to
say that our expense suppose we want to
buy some coffee and let's say the date
would be for the first of April so we
can use the sigil and we can say we want
to schedule for the date and the date is
going to be 2023 the month is April the
date is the 1st of April let's say the
amount for this one is going to be 10
and let's say we buy this from Metro so
now we have one expense with us now let
us try adding this expense so we can say
expense dot add our expense and let us
pass the newly created expense
and we get back an answer so let us see
if we have coffee in this list or not
so yes as we can see the first item is
the coffee so we have added our expense
inside the list so let us go back and
let us see what else we can do next let
us see how we can update a single entry
inside our list of expenses so for
example let's see how we can update an
amount for a particular expense so let
us create a function and let us call the
function as update amount now this
function will take two parameters the
first parameter is the title for our
expense and the second can be the amount
so the updated amount and let us see how
we can write the body for this one so
for example what I want to do is
suppose we are buying Grocery and we
want to update the amount from 18.99 to
say 20 dollars so let's see how we can
do that
so for updating the amount we have to do
a couple of things so the first thing is
we need to filter out the expense that
we want to update the second step is we
want to create a new expense with the
updated amount because remember all of
the data types in Elixir are immutable
the third is we simply want to add this
expense to our samples and we want to
take out the old entry so let us see how
we can do these things so the first step
is to filter the exact expense with the
given title so we can say we want to use
enum.filter the first argument would be
for our sample expenses so we can just
pass the function of sample over here
next we have to define a function right
over here so let me use the function and
end and for each iteration this function
receives one single expense so let us
pattern match on the expense title so
here we can say that we want to extract
the title and we want to capture the
title in a new variable and let us name
the variable as expand title and for
each iteration we simply have to check
if the expense title is equal to the
given title so this title comes from the
functional definition which is right
over here and we also need to capture
this expense so if you just hover on
filter so here we can see that the
result is a list so let us pattern match
and let us extract that expense so on
the left let us pattern match over here
and let us create a new list and let us
create a variable called as item so this
item will hold the expense that we have
just filtered the next step is to create
a new expense so we can say that we want
to create a variable for the new item
and let us create a new expense by
updating this item so we can say for my
struct of item I want to update the
amount by the new amount so this amount
comes from the function definition right
over here so now we have the new amount
the last thing is we simply have to
append the new item to our list of
samples but before we can append we also
need to remove the old item from our
list of samples but we can do all of
these things in one place in a single
statement so let me show you how we can
do this so here we can say that we want
to append the new item to our list of
our samples but before we can append we
also need to remove the old entry so
what we can do is we can simply take the
output of sample and pipe this into a
new function and we can say list dot
delete and let me pass the old item to
this function and that's it so what's
going to happen is first we are going to
remove the entry from the list of
samples and after that the new item is
going to be appended now let me open up
the terminal and as usual let us again
recompile our expense let me clear up
the screen and let us try to invoke this
function expense dot update amount now
for example we want to update the amount
of our grocery from 18.9 99 to say
thirty dollars and let us check if we
have updated the amount or not so yes so
this is the entry for grocery and the
new amount is 30. so let us go back so
till now we have seen a lot of different
ways in which we can work with our
structs we have seen how to work with
recursion and we have also seen how to
work with the inbuilt modules now for
the last thing in this video I wanted to
show you the with statements so for
example what happens we may have to deal
with multiple conditions so for example
you are writing a web application and
you want to have the function ID for
login now in order to login a user we
have to satisfy a multiple of different
conditions for example first we need to
authenticate and then we also need to
verify the password and so on so
basically what we want to do is in order
to log in we have to satisfy multiple of
conditions and you can satisfy multiple
conditions by using the with syntax so
let me show you first and it will be
easy for you to understand so the first
thing is let us create a dummy database
for our users and we can do that by
writing our own custom model attributes
so here we can say that we want to
define a model attribute by the name of
users and let us assign a list of
different users so what we have done is
so this is a model attribute and we have
assigned a list of different uses for
this model attribute so what happens is
we can use this users as a constant
throughout our module next let us write
some dummy functions to authenticate and
verify password so here I can say that I
want to define a function to
authenticate and this function will
accept a user and here what we can do is
we can use something which is called as
a function guard so here we can say that
when the user is in my list of our users
only at that time I want to return a
tuple and the first element would be ok
and the message would be authorized so
this syntax that you can see over here
the is called as guards so in Elixir we
can use different kinds of guards so you
will understand guards as and when you
learn more of Elixir but for now let us
just go with the flow next let us create
one more functional definition for our
authenticate so in case we don't have
the user inside our database so at that
time we want to return a tuple the first
element would be error and we can send
back a message called as unauthorized
next let us create some dummy functions
for verify password as well so you can
say we want to Define verify password
now this function will accept two
parameters the first is going to be the
user and the second is going to be the
password and here also we can use the
function guard so we can say in case the
user is inside our database of users
only at that time I want to return back
at Apple the first element is going to
be okay and then we can pass the message
as password verified now in case the
username and the password does not match
so for this one let us create one more
Clause so this I don't need a guard for
this one and this has to be error and
let us pass the message as wrong
password and this case since we're not
doing anything with the password let me
use an underscore and here also we are
not doing anything with the user and the
password okay so now we have the basic
framework in place now let us create a
function for login so we can say Define
login now this function accepts the user
and also a password now let me take all
of these things a little up now in order
to log in a user we have to satisfy a
couple of different conditions the first
condition is first we have to
authenticate and then we also have to
verify the password so let us see how we
can use the with syntax so first let me
write the width block over here so with
do and we can also write the else block
over here now let's see how we can
Define the body of our width so in order
to log in first we need to authenticate
and we also need to verify at the same
time now here let us call the function
of authenticate and let us pass the user
now we have to say that we have to
satisfy this condition and we can
specify that by using an arrow syntax
over here and we can specify that in
case we get a specific output only then
the user can be authenticated and here
we can specify that in case the first
element is the atom of ok and then we
get some kind of a message back only in
that case the user would be
authenticated now this is the first case
of authenticate but we also need to
check if we can verify the password or
not so here let us call the function of
verify password let us pass the user and
let us also pass the password now we can
say that this function of verify
password also has to satisfy a couple of
different conditions so let me just copy
this one from here and let me paste it
right over here so in case this function
also succeeds and we get back at Apple
with OK and suppose the second one is
for the message message let me put an
underscore over here since we are not
doing anything with the variable so now
what we are trying to do is we are
trying to check for two different
conditions authenticate and verify and
in case we satisfy both of these
functions then we can say that we want
to return back a message so the first
would be the item of ok and then let's
create a string so we can say the user
logged in successfully but in case the
function of authenticate or verify
password fails so in that case we'll go
to the else block now here we can
pattern match on multiple conditions in
case we get a tuple back and the first
element is the item of error the second
could be some kind of a message so at
that time we simply want to return back
the same thing so we want to return back
the Tuple of error and the message back
but in case we get some other error so
we can specify that by using the
underscore so in all other cases we
simply want to return back and atom
saying that this is an unauthorized
operation or I forgot to put a comma
over here so this is how your width
block looks like so let me open up my
terminal and let us see this thing in
action so let me recompile my model of
expense let me clear the screen and here
we can say that from expense Dot Login
and first let us pass a user which is
there inside our database for example we
have the user of Lewis inside our
database so let us pause the argument of
Lewis and for the password it does not
matter because we are not doing anything
with the password and let us see what
kind of output we are getting so yes we
get back the message saying that Lewis
logged in successfully let's try this
one more time with the user who does not
exist so let me change the spelling and
this time we get back the message as
error unauthorized so this was all about
using the width syntax with our Elixir
well that's it for this video and I will
catch you in the next one
hi and welcome to the last section of
our entire series now this last part or
the last section is all all about
building a statistics library in elixir
now don't worry about the word or
statistics there is nothing big about
statistics as long as you know your
basic mathematics like addition
subtraction Division and so on you would
be absolutely fine you don't have to
worry now I also wanted to discuss about
a couple of things regarding functional
programming my first question is do you
have a hard time understanding
functional programming if your answer is
yes then don't worry you are on the
right track
now what I mean to say is our brains are
so much used to the the object oriented
programming paradigms or the imperative
programming paradigms that it takes some
time for you to understand about your
data immutability and recursion so don't
worry the only thing that you need is
more practice and the intent behind
creating one more project is to give you
more practice isn't it so don't worry
and this is going to be a very nice
project I will show you how we can
slightly architect our code in a much
better way how we can create a different
public API how we can separate our in
our internal implementation from the
public API and so on so overall this is
going to be a very nice project so hang
on with me and I will catch you right in
the next video till then bye so let's
get started with our statistics project
but before that I would like you to meet
my friend Luis now Lewis stays in
Toronto and he owns a Candies store and
Lewis is going to help us to learn more
about statistics
the first topic that we want to learn is
called as central tendency so central
tendency is like a big chapter but don't
worry I will make it very simple for you
the first thing that we want to study is
how we can calculate a mean now mean is
nothing it's just a glorified word for
average so let us try and study a little
bit more about this Concepts
now since Lewis stays in Toronto Lewis
wants to count the number of cars in
Toronto so this kind of data is called
as your population data now this kind of
data is called as population because our
entire scope of data is just Toronto
right we only want to count the number
of cars which are there in Toronto so
this number of cars is going to be a
finite number and our scope or our range
of data is limited just to Toronto
that's why this kind of data is called
as your population data now let us see
next what's going to happen
so next Lewis wants to count the number
of cars in Toronto but this time the
data is different Lewis wants to count
the number of cars in Toronto out of all
of the cars in Canada so this time what
is happening is the number of cars in
Toronto becomes your sample data now the
reason why this data becomes sample data
is we are taking a small subset of cars
in Toronto from a bigger set of data
which is all of the cars in Canada
so all of the cars in Canada is your
population and since we are taking a
small subset of cars just in Toronto
that's why this kind of data becomes
your sample data so let us have a look
at one more example
for example Lewis wants to calculate the
average height of people in his house
so for example if there are four people
staying in his house then that data
becomes the population data now what's
happening in this case is the number of
people are just limited to the house of
Lewis and that's why the data is your
population data and we are trying to
calculate the average height that's why
we simply have to calculate the
population mean for this kind of data
the next is Lewis wants to calculate the
average height of people in Toronto out
of all of the people in Canada now
what's happening in this case all of the
people in Canada this data is your
population data and what we are
targeting is we are targeting just the
people who stay in Toronto
so this data is your sample data that's
why this average is going to be your
sample mean right let's have a look at
one more example
now Lewis owns a candy store in Toronto
and Lois wants to calculate the average
number of candies sold in three hours
now what kind of a data would this be
would this be a population data or would
this be a sample data the answer is this
is going to be a population data because
our scope is just limited to three hours
and since this is a population data we
would be calculating the population mean
so for example this other different
candies which are sold by Lewis in the
first hour Lewis could sell 10 candies
for the second hour Lewis sold 20
candies and for the third hour Lewis
sold 30 candies
so let us see how we can calculate the
mean for this kind of data so we have to
just add all of the candies together so
that's what we are doing right over here
and then we simply have to divide by
three so we get the answer as 20 candies
for an hour that means Lewis was able to
sell on an average 20 candidates per
hour for the first three hours
now let us have a look at one more
example now this time Lewis wants to
calculate the average candidates sold in
the first three hours out of the entire
day now in this case the full day would
be your population data and since we are
just limited to the first three hours
out of the full day that means this is
going to be our sample data which means
we have to calculate the sample mean now
these are the different candies which
are sold by Lewis throughout eight hours
in the day so for the first hour he sold
10 candies for the second hour 20
candies for the third hour 30 candies
and so on so let us see how we can
calculate the mean in this case
so again everything Remains the Same for
the first three hours we have the same
figures so 10 candies for the first hour
20 for the second 30 for the next so
that's why we have 10 plus 20 plus 30
and the number of hours for which we are
calculating is three that's why we have
three over here and again this evaluates
to 20 that means for the first three
hours in the entire day Lewis was able
to sell 20 candies in an hour so you can
see that the formula for the mean
Remains the Same so what's the
difference the difference is in
perspective
sample data is different and population
data is different so keep this
perspective in your mind and let us see
how we can code this population and
Sample mean right in the next video
let us get started with our statistics
project
so let me open up my terminal and let's
create a new mix project
so let me go inside my folder of
functional programming with Elixir and
then let me go inside my folder of code
and right over here I want to create a
new project so I can say mix
new stats and let me open up the folder
in a new window so this is going to be
our new statistics project so let us see
how we can Implement our population and
Sample mean functionality so the first
thing is inside the folder of lib let me
create a new folder and let me call that
folder as central tendency now inside
this folder let us create another file
so let me create a file and this is
going to be for calculating our
population and Sample mean let me
collapse my sidebar and first let us
Define a module so this is going to be
stats dot central tendency dot mean so
here first let us see how we can
calculate our population mean now the
formula for calculating the population
mean is very simple we simply have to
take the sum and we have to divide that
sum with our count now in terms of
statistics this sum is also called as
Sigma so let us see how we can calculate
our population mean first so let's
define a function called as population
mean this function accepts a list of our
numbers so we can call the argument as
numbers and let us see how we can Define
the body for this function but before we
can Define the body here we need to do a
lot of validation the first validation
that we need to do is we need to check
if this numbers is actually a list or
not so for this we are going to use a
guard so let us go to the official
documentation and let us try and see if
we can find the Right Guard or not so
inside the model of Kernel we have a
section for guards so let us check if we
can find the guard for list or not so if
I scroll a little bit down here we have
one God and this guard is right over
here is list so let us see how you can
use this guard in our function
so here what we can say that we want to
have a guard saying that is list and let
us pass the variable of numbers so
basically what we want to do is we want
to run this function only when this
numbers is a list now we have validated
that this numbers is a list but what
happens if this numbers is not a list or
in case the numbers is an empty list so
let's define one more function overload
on the top so here we can Define that we
want to define the same function
population mean and in case if we get a
blank list then at that time written
back a blank list now we can either
written back a blank list or we can also
written some kind of an error so for
example if you want to return some kind
of an error so we can return back at
Apple and we can say that this is going
to be an error and we can also return
back a message saying that invalid data
type so it's up to you if you want you
can get return back a blank list or you
can return back an error table so this
is just for your reference so now let us
see how we can Define the actual body
for our population mean so here we need
to do two things first we need to find
out the sum or the sigma and then we
have to divide by the count but before
we do all of these things we need to do
one more validation so till now what we
have validated is that this numbers is
just a list but we also need to validate
that this is a list of numbers so let us
see how we can validate this one so here
let us create a pipeline so here we can
say that first I want you to take the
numbers and then I want you to pipe
these numbers inside a function and we
can call that function as validate our
number list so we have not defined this
function but let's define it right over
here so let me just copy this one and
let us Define a function right over here
so validate our numbers list this X
accept our list of numbers and let us
see how we can Define the body for this
one now for this function Let Us return
back a tuple the first condition would
be either true or false the second
condition would be the numbers so in
case if this list is not a list of
numbers we will send back false but in
case this is a valid list of numbers
then we will send back a true right over
here so let us see how we can do this
thing unfortunately it's very simple so
here let us use the inbuilt module of
enum and I want to use the function of
all now this all takes two arguments the
first is going to be our enum so let us
pass the enum of our numbers and this
also takes a function so let us Define a
function right over here now what
happens for each iteration we are going
to receive an element from our list of
numbers and we simply have to check if
that element is a number or not so here
we can use an inbuilt function called as
is number and let us pass the element to
this one and that's it we have defined a
function to validate all our numbers as
well let us also write the type
specification for this function so here
we can say that the specs for validate
number lists so this receives a list of
our numbers and this function returns a
tuple the first is going to be our
Boolean the second element is our list
of numbers let us go back to our
function of population mean so now we
have all of the validation in place now
this function returns back a tuple so
what we can do is we can simply take
that Tuple and we can pipe the output in
here another functions so let us call
the new function as calculate population
mean so we have not yet defined this
function but let's define it right over
here so here we can say that Define
calculate population mean and let us
write the do and end blocks now this
function of calculate population mean
receives a tuple right the first is our
condition the second one is our list of
numbers now this condition can either be
true or it can be false so suppose we
have a true condition then we can have a
pattern match right over here but in
case if it is false then we can create
yet another Clause so let me just copy
and paste this one so here I can say
that in case the argument is false and
we don't have to do anything with
numbers so let me replace numbers with
my underscore in case the first argument
is false that means the validation has
failed so here we can again send the
same Tuple error so let me copy this one
and let me paste it right over here now
let us see how we can calculate the
population mean in case the first
argument is true now here the formula is
very simple first we have to take the
numbers next we have to calculate the
sum and we can calculate the sum by
using an inbuilt function so we can say
enum dot sum the next one is we simply
have to divide the sum with the count so
for this let us Define one more function
and let us call that function as mean so
this function is going to receive two
arguments the first argument would be
for the sigma which comes from this one
the second argument would be for the
count and we can pass the second
argument right over here so we can say
enum dot count and let us pass the list
of numbers now let us create this
function right over here so we can say
Define mean the first argument is for
the sigma the second argument is for the
count and for this one the
implementation is very easy we simply
have to divide the sigma with the count
and that's it we have implemented
population mean but we can do a lot of
improvements so as you can see we have
some repetition we have this couple of
error here as well as on the top as well
let me also put some separator lines for
our convenience so this is going to be a
separate thing and calculation for the
population mean is going to be a
separate section and one for this one as
well so now let us go to the top and let
us see how we can improve our code so
now the first thing is we have this
error Tuple twice so let's create a
separate model for errors so let me open
up my sidebar and inside the directory
of lib let me create a new model called
as errors and let us Define the module
as stats dot errors let us Define a
function over here so we can say Define
invalid data types and we simply want to
return back the Tuple so let me go back
to the file of mean and let me just copy
this line let us go back to our errors
file and let me paste it right over here
now let us go back to this file let me
collapse my sidebar and now what we can
do is we can create an alias on the top
so we can say that let us create an
aliens for our star ads dot errors and
we can replace this line with errors dot
invalid data type and we can do the same
thing right over here so let me take out
this line and we can say that errors dot
invalid data type now I want to do one
more thing I want to take out this
function of validate into yet another
module and this is because I simply know
that we would require this validation
function for our future implementation
as well so inside lip let us create one
more file for validators again let us
Define the module and the model name has
to be stats dot validators let us go
back to this file I simply want to cut
everything out so let me take it out and
let us go to our file of validators and
let me paste it right over here now for
this one we can do one slide validation
since we have taken this file inside
another module so here we can do one
small validation as well so let's define
a guard over here so when is list for
our numbers and in case if this
validation fails then let us create one
more Clause right over here so here we
can simply ignore the argument and we
can simply return back an error so let
me again create an alias for the error
right over here so let's create an alias
for our Stacks dot errors and let us
return an error right over here so here
we can say that errors dot invalid data
type now the specification for this one
is going to change so this function of
invalid data type this returns a tuple
let us Define a specification for this
one as well so let us go to errors and
here we can say that the specification
for our function of invalid data type so
this function does not accept anything
and this simply written backs an atom
and the next argument is of the type of
string so let me copy all of these
things let us go back to our file of
validators so now what's happening is in
case if this number but is a list of
numbers we send back a tuple but in case
the validation fails then we simply send
back an error and the format for the
error is we have an atom and we also
have a message right the next thing is
since we have taken this function in a
different module let us go back to our
model of mean and let us create an alias
on the top so here we can say that we
want to Alias yet another module so we
can say that we want to Alias stats dot
validators now what we are doing is we
are importing errors and validators from
the same model of stats so we can create
an alias on the same line let me show
you how so we just have to wrap this
inside our curly brackets and we can say
that we also want to create an alias for
validators as well now right over here
on line number 10 this function is
inside our model of validators so
validators dot validate numbers list let
me take out this lines let me open up my
terminal and we can go inside our IEX
let us create an alias for stats dot
central tendency dot mean let me clear
up everything and let us call our
population mean so we can say population
mean and let us pass 10 20 and 30 and as
expected we get back the answer as 20.
now let us pass an empty list and see
what's happening so in this case we are
getting back an error saying that error
invalid data type now watch what happens
if we pass some other argument for
example if we pass a b and c so in this
case we get an error saying that no
function Clause matching and this is
because we have not defined a catch all
clause for this function of population
mean so let us Define one Clause right
over here so here we can say that define
population mean and in this case we
simply want to ignore the argument and
we simply want to return back our errors
dot invalid data type let me open up the
terminal and let us recompile our model
of mean let me clear up everything and
let us try the same statement one more
time so this time we get a nice error
saying that error invalid data type so
this is how we can create population
mean but we are not yet done we also
need to implement the sample mean but
luckily the formula for sample mean and
population mean is the same so let us
very quickly Implement our sample mean
as well let me take out all of the
comments I don't need the comments let
me paste the separator line on top now
here let me again copy this separator
line and let us create one more function
for sample mean right over here so here
we can say that we want to define a
function for our sample mean now this
function accepts a list of numbers and
we simply have to call our population
mean and pass our list of numbers so
that's it now we have the function for
sample mean and population mean as well
let us also Define find the
specifications for this function so here
we can say that the specifications for
our population mean now this function
receives a list of numbers and this
function is going to return back a
number or it is going to return back an
error now the type of our error is like
this the first element is the atom and
the second element is of the type of
string let me copy this specification
for our sample mean as well let me paste
it right here and let me change the name
from population to sample next we can do
a couple of more implements for our code
now if you see this function of
calculate population mean and this
function of mean so this functions are
just our private functions so let us
declare them as private so this becomes
our F of p and this also becomes our
private function the same thing happens
for our mean as well this also becomes
our private function now let me open up
the terminal let us try and recompile
this one more time let me clear up
everything and let us try to invoke the
same function one more time let us pass
the list of 10 20 and 30 so this is for
the population mean and let us try the
same thing for our sample mean as well
so let me replace this with sample mean
and we get the same answer back now
what's happening is every time we have
to create an alias but instead what we
can do is we can separate our public API
from our private API so if I open up my
sidebar we have a model for stats.ex and
as you can see that this file is not
doing anything so what we want to do is
we want to make this stats file as our
public API so what I mean to say is the
end users can just reference this single
file to use all of the functionality so
let me show you how we can do this let
me take out all of these things these
are not required let me collapse the
sidebar and let let us Define a function
for our population mean right over here
now this function receives the list of
our numbers and from here we can simply
call our function of population mean so
we can say that we want to create an
alias for our stats dot central tendency
dot mean and for this function we can
simply delegate it to mean dot
population mean and let us pass the
argument of numbers so now we have
simplified our API quite a lot now let
me open up the terminal let us recompile
the model of stacks let me clear up
everything now what we can do is we can
simply call stats dot population mean
and let us pass the argument of 10 20
and 30 and we get back the right answer
now let us go back to our code and we
can do one slide Improvement for this
one now instead of just calling this
function we can use something which is
called as def delegate so first let me
show you and then I can explain it to
you so here we can use the new keyword
called as def delegate the first
argument is the name of our function so
the name of our function is population
mean so let me paste it right over here
now this function also accepts one
argument and the argument is for the
list of our numbers and now what we want
to do is we simply want to delegate this
function to our model of mean and that's
it line number four and line number five
does the exact same thing so let me
comment on this line This is not
required let me open up my terminal let
us recompile the model of stats let me
clear up everything and let me call the
same function one more time and as
expected this is working just fine let
us create one word of Delegate for the
sample mean so here we simply have to
change the name from population mean to
sample mean so whenever we call stats
dot sample mean this function would be
delegated to main dot sample mean let me
open up my terminal let us recompile the
same module let me clear up everything
and here I can say that stats dot this
time I want to calculate the sample mean
and let me pass the argument of three
four five six and seven and this time we
get the answer as 5 well that's it for
this video and I will catch you in the
next one let us get started with our
statistics project
so let me open up my terminal and let's
create a new mix project
so let me go inside my folder of
functional programming with Elixir and
then let me go inside my folder of code
and right over here I want to create a
new project so I can say mix
new stats and let me open up the folder
in a new window so this is going to be
our new statistics project so let us see
how we can Implement our population and
Sample mean functionality so the first
thing is inside the folder of flip let
me create a new folder and let me call
that folder as central tendency now
inside this folder let us create another
file so let me create a file and this is
going to be for calculating our
population and Sample mean let me
collapse my sidebar and first let us
Define a module so this is going to be
stats dot central tendency dot mean so
here first let us see how we can
calculate our population mean now the
formula for calculating the population
mean is very simple we simply have to
take the sum and we have to divide that
sum with our count now in terms of
statistics this sum is also called as
Sigma so let us see how we can calculate
our population mean first so let's
define a function called as population
mean this function accepts a list of our
numbers so we can call the argument as
numbers and let us see how we can Define
the body for this function but before we
can Define the body here we need to do a
lot of validation the first validation
that we need to do is we need to check
if this numbers is actually a list or
not so for this we are going to use a
guard so let us go to the official
documentation and let us try and see if
we can find the Right Guard or not so
inside the model of Kernel we have a
section for guards so let us check if we
can find the guard for list or not so if
I scroll a little bit down here we have
one God and this guard is right over
here is list so let us see how you can
use this guard in our function
so here what we can say that we want to
have a guard saying that is list and let
us pass the variable of numbers so
basically what we want to do is we want
to run this function only when this
numbers is a list now we have validated
that this numbers is a list but what
happens if this numbers is not a list or
in case the numbers is an empty list so
let's define one more function overload
on the top so here we can Define that we
want to define the same function
population mean and in case if we get a
blank list then at that time written
back a blank list now we can either
written back a blank list or we can also
written some kind of an error so for
example if you want to return some kind
of an error so we can written back at
Apple and we can say that this is going
to be an error and we can also return
back a message saying that invalid data
like so it's up to you if you want you
can get return back a blank list or you
can return back an erratable so this is
just for your reference so now let us
see how we can Define the actual body
for our population mean so here we need
to do two things first we need to find
out the sum or the sigma and then we
have to divide by the count but before
we do all of these things we need to do
one more validation so till now what we
have validated is that this numbers is
just a list but we also need to validate
that this is a list of numbers so let us
see how we can validate this one so here
let us create a pipeline so here we can
say that first I want you to take the
numbers and then I want you to pipe
these numbers inside a function and we
can call that function as validate our
number list so we have not defined this
function but let's define it right over
here so let me just copy this one and
let us Define a function right over here
so validate our numbers list this X
accept our list of numbers and let us
see how we can Define the body for this
one now for this function Let Us return
back a tuple the first condition would
be either true or false the second
condition would be the numbers so in
case if this list is not a list of
numbers we will send back false but in
case this is a valid list of numbers
then we will send back a true right over
here so let us see how we can do this
thing unfortunately it's very simple so
here let us use the inbuilt module of
enum and I want to use the function of
all now this all takes two arguments the
first is going to be our enum so let us
pass the enum of our numbers and this
also takes a function so let us Define a
function right over here now what
happens for each iteration we are going
to receive an element from our list of
numbers and we simply have to check if
that element is a number or not so here
we can use an inbuilt function called as
is number and let us pass the element to
this one and that's it we have defined a
function to validate all our numbers as
well let us also write the type
specification for this function so here
we can say that the specs for validate
number lists so this receives a list of
our numbers and this function returns at
Apple the first is going to be our
Boolean the second element is our list
of numbers let us go back to our
function of population mean so now we
have all of the validation in place now
this function returns back a tuple so
what we can do is we can simply take
that Tuple and we can pipe the output in
here another function so let us call the
new function as calculate population
mean so we have not yet defined this
function but let's define it right over
here so here we can say that Define
calculate population mean and let us
write the do and end blocks now this
function of calculate population mean
receives a tuple right the first is our
condition the second one is our list of
numbers now this condition can either be
true or it can be false so suppose we
have a true condition then we can have a
pattern match right over here but in
case if it is false then we can create
yet another Clause so let me just copy
and paste this one so here I can say
that in case the argument is false and
we don't have to do anything with
numbers so let me replace numbers with
my underscore in case the first argument
is false that means the validation has
failed so here we can again send the
same Apple error so let me copy this one
and let me paste it right over here now
let us see how we can calculate the
population mean in case the first
argument is true now here the formula is
very simple first we have to take the
numbers next we have to calculate the
sum and we can calculate the sum by
using an inbuilt function so we can say
enum dot sum the next one is we simply
have to divide the sum with the count so
for this let us Define one more function
and let us call that function as mean so
this function is going to receive two
arguments the first argument would be
for the sigma which comes from this one
the second argument would be for the
count and we can pass the second
argument right over here so we can say
enum dot count and let us pass the list
of numbers now let us create this
function right over here so we can say
Define mean the first argument is for
the sigma the second argument is for the
count and for this one the
implementation is very easy we simply
have to divide the sigma with the count
and that's it we have implemented
population mean but we can do a lot of
improvements so as you can see we have
some repetition we have this couple of
error here as well as on the top as well
let me also put some separator lines for
our convenience so this is going to be a
separate thing and calculation for the
population mean is going to be a
separate section and one for this one as
well so now let us go to the top and let
us see how we can improve our code so
now the first thing is we have this
error Tuple twice so let's create a
separate model for errors so let me open
up my sidebar and inside the directory
of lib let me create a new model called
as errors and let us Define the module
as stats dot errors let us Define a
function over here so we can say Define
invalid data types and we simply want to
return back the Tuple so let me go back
to the file of mean and let me just copy
this line let us go back to our errors
file and let me paste it right over here
now let us go back to this file let me
collapse my sidebar and now what we can
do is we can create an alias on the top
so we can say that let us create an
aliens for our star ads dot errors and
we can replace this line with errors dot
invalid data type and we can do the same
thing right over here so let me take out
this line and we can say that errors dot
invalid data type now I want to do one
more thing I want to take out this
function of validate into yet another
module and this is because I simply know
that we would require this validation
function for our future implementation
as well so inside lip let us create one
more file for validators again let us
Define the module and the model name has
to be stats dot validators let us go
back to this file I simply want to cut
everything out so let me take it out and
let us go to our file of validators and
let me paste it right over here now for
this one we can do one slide validation
since we have taken this file inside
another module so here we can do one
small validation as well so let's define
a guard over here so when is list for
our numbers and in case if this
validation fails then let us create one
more Clause right over here so here we
can simply ignore the argument and we
can simply return back an error so let
me again create an alias for the error
right over here so let's create an alias
for our Stacks dot errors and let us
return an error right over here so here
we can say that errors dot invalid data
type now the specification for this one
is going to change so this function of
invalid data type this returns a tuple
let us Define a specification for this
one as well so let us go to errors and
here we can say that the specification
for our function of invalid data type so
this function does not accept anything
and this simply written backs an atom
and the next argument is of the type of
string so let me copy all of these
things let us go back to our file of
validators so now what's happening is in
case if this number is a list of numbers
we send back a tuple but in case the
validation fails then we simply send
back an error and the format for the
error is we have an atom and we also
have a message right the next thing is
since we have taken this function in a
different module let us go back to our
model of mean and let us create an alias
on the top so here we can say that we
want to Alias yet another module so we
can say that we want to Alias stats dot
validators now what we are doing is we
are importing errors and validators from
the same model of stats so we can create
an alias on the same line let me show
you how so we just have to wrap this
inside our curly brackets and we can say
that we also want to create an alias for
validators as well now right over here
on line number 10 this function is
inside our model of validators so
validators dot validate numbers list let
me take out this lines let me open up my
terminal and we can go inside our IEX
let us create an alias for stats dot
central tendency dot mean let me clear
up everything and let us call our
population mean so we can say population
mean and let us pass 10 20 and 30 and as
expected we get back the answer as 20.
now let us pass an empty list and see
what's happening so in this case we are
getting back an error saying that error
invalid data type now watch what happens
if we pass some other argument for
example if we pass a b and c so in this
case we get an error saying that no
function Clause matching and this is
because we have not defined a catch all
clause for this function of population
mean so let us Define one Clause right
over here so here we can say that define
population mean and in this case we
simply want to ignore the argument and
we simply want to return back our errors
dot invalid data type let me open up the
terminal and let us recompile our model
of mean let me clear up everything and
let us try the same statement one more
time so this time we get a nice error
saying that error invalid data type so
this is how we can create population
mean but we are not yet done we also
need to implement the sample mean but
luckily the formula for sample mean and
population mean is the same so let us
very quickly Implement our sample mean
as well let me take out all of the
comments I don't need the comments let
me paste the separator line on top now
here let me again copy this separator
line and let us create one more function
for sample mean right over here so here
we can say that we want to define a
function for our sample mean now this
function accepts a list of numbers and
we simply have to call our population
mean and pass our list of numbers so
that's it now we have the function for
sample mean and population mean as well
let us also Define find the
specifications for this function so here
we can say that the specifications for
our population mean now this function
receives a list of numbers and this
function is going to return back a
number or it is going to return back an
error now the type of our error is like
this the first element is the atom and
the second element is of the type of
string let me copy this specification
for our sample mean as well let me paste
it right here and let me change the name
from population to sample next we can do
a couple of more implements for our code
now if you see this function of
calculate population mean and this
function of mean so this functions are
just our private functions so let us
declare them as private so this becomes
our F of p and this also becomes our
private function the same thing happens
for our mean as well this also becomes
our private function now let me open up
the terminal let us try and recompile
this one more time let me clear up
everything and let us try to invoke the
same function one more time let us pass
the list of 10 20 and 30 so this is for
the population mean and let us try the
same thing for our sample mean as well
so let me replace this with sample mean
and we get the same answer back now
what's happening is every time we have
to create an alias but instead what we
can do is we can separate our public API
from our private API so if I open up my
sidebar we have a model for stats.ex and
as you can see that this file is not
doing anything so what we want to do is
we want to make this stats file as our
public API so what I mean to say is the
end users can just reference this single
file to use all of the functionality so
let me show you how we can do this let
me take out all of these things these
are not required let me collapse the
sidebar and let let us Define a function
for our population mean right over here
now this function receives the list of
our numbers and from here we can simply
call our function of population mean so
we can say that we want to create an
alias for our stats dot central tendency
dot mean and for this function we can
simply delegate it to mean dot
population mean and let us pass the
argument of numbers so now we have
simplified our API quite a lot now let
me open up the terminal let us recompile
the model of stacks let me clear up
everything now what we can do is we can
simply call stats dot population mean
and let us pass the argument of 10 20
and 30 and we get back the right answer
now let us go back to our code and we
can do one slide Improvement for this
one now instead of just calling this
function we can use something which is
called as def delegate so first let me
show you and then I can explain it to
you so here we can use the new keyword
called as def delegate the first
argument is the name of our function so
the name of our function is population
mean so let me paste it right over here
now this function also accepts one
argument and the argument is for the
list of our numbers and now what we want
to do is we simply want to delegate this
function to our model of mean and that's
it line number four and line number five
does the exact same thing so let me
comment on this line This is not
required let me open up my terminal let
us recompile the model of stats let me
clear up everything and let me call the
same function one more time and as
expected this is working just fine let
us create one word of Delegate for the
sample mean so here we simply have to
change the name from population mean to
sample mean so whenever we call stats
dot sample mean this function would be
delegated to main dot sample mean let me
open up my terminal let us recompile the
same module let me clear up everything
and here I can say that Stacks dot this
time I want to calculate the sample mean
and let me pass the argument of three
four five six and seven and this time we
get the answer as 5 well that's it for
this video and I will catch you in the
next one now let us move on to the next
part and let us see how we can calculate
something which is called as a median
now what I've done is behind the scenes
I have created a new file called as
median and I have also defined the model
for this one
and to make things simple I have added a
lot of documentation so let us see what
do we exactly mean by the median so let
us have a look at this scenario right
over here
so suppose Lewis is selling candies for
9 hours and these are the sales of the
candies for each respect to hour for the
first hour Lewis could sell 10 candies
for the second hour Lewis sold 40
candies for the third he sold 20 and so
on so these are the number of candies
that Lewis sold each hour throughout
nine hours of his shift now let us see
what do you exactly mean by median so
median is nothing it is just a central
value or it's just the value that
divides the measurement into two equal
parts
so what we want to achieve is we want to
find a value that will divide our
measurements in the first 50 percent and
the next 50 percent and it's very easy
to calculate median as well so this is
going to be a very simple algorithm for
calculating the median the first step in
our algorithm is sorting our list so
here we can see we have a sorted list of
all of the sales of candies for the
first nine hours
for the second part of our algorithm is
we need to count the number of elements
inside our list
and now here there can be two things
first if our account is odd and the
second one is if the count is even now
if the count is odd then the things are
very simple we simply take the middle
value and that value becomes our median
so for example in this case 50 is right
at the center we have four values to the
left and we have four values to the
right so 50 becomes our median
the next scenario is what happens if the
count is even at that time what we do is
we take two values from the center so in
this case 40 and 50 are two values now
just have a look at this list this list
contains only eight values I have taken
out the last value of 90 from this list
now since this is an even list we simply
take two values from the center
so we have 40 and 50 as the center so as
you can see there are three values to
the left and we have three values to the
right and then we simply average them
out so 40 plus 50 divided by 2 and we
get the answer as 45 and 45 becomes your
median value
so this is how we are going to implement
our algorithm for calculating the median
so let us see how we can translate all
of these things into code so let me go
to the top and here we can see that I
have defined a model by the name of
stats dot central tendency dot median
and now let's get started with this one
let us Define the very first function
and let us call the function as median
this function is going to accept a list
of our numbers so we can call the
argument as numbers list and let us also
use the guard right over here so we can
say when is a list and it has passed the
argument of our number list
so this is one scenario and the next
scenario could be we don't get a proper
list over here so for handling that case
let us Define
one more version so we can say median we
simply want to ignore the input and we
simply want to throw an error but first
we need to create an aliens so it's very
easy for us to use those modules
so let me create an alias for our stats
dot errors
and here we can say that we simply want
to return our errors dot invalid data
type now let us go back to this function
and let us see how we can implement this
one
so the first thing is we need to
validate our list of numbers so again
let me create one more areas at the top
so here I can say that
we want to create yet another Alias and
this time it's for stats dot our
validators and now let us go down right
over here so here what we can do is we
can simply take the list of our numbers
and then we can pipe this list of
numbers inside our validators DOT
validate numbers list
and after we validate our numbers list
then we can pipe the output into yet
another function by the name of
calculated median now we don't have that
function as of now but we will create it
shortly let me put a separator line over
here and here let us Define the function
of calculate median now let me scroll
slightly up so that everything is
visible
now let us see what this function is
going to receive
so the output of this function validate
numbers list is going to be pipe into
the function of calculate median
and as you can see this function either
returns a Boolean and our numbers list
or it Returns the atom along with the
error message
so let us pattern match on various
scenarios and let us see how we can
handle different cases the first and the
most easiest one is just to handle the
error so in case we get an input like
this we get an error and the second
argument is a message at that time we
can simply return back the Tuple of
error
and the message as it is or what we can
do is we can simply use the errors
module so either you can do this or we
can simply call errors dot invalid data
types now let us see what more we can do
with this function
now the function of validate numbers
list can also give us a tuple where the
first argument is a Boolean and the
second argument is the list of numbers
so let us pattern match on this scenario
and let us see how we can work with this
one so let me Define yet another
function oh one more thing what we can
do is we can simply mark this function
to be private now since this is going to
be our helper function we don't want to
expose the functionality outside
so I am simply marking this function as
a private function now let us have one
more pattern match right over here
now what happens if the first argument
is false
so at that time we can simply ignore the
second argument we don't want the second
argument so in this case also since the
validation has failed let us again send
back the error so we can say errors dot
invalid data type now let us Define the
third scenario as well so again let us
Define the private function calculate
median and this time it receives a tuple
where the first argument is true and the
second argument is our list of numbers
here let us see how we can Define the
body for this calculated median function
let us go slightly up and let us have a
look at our algorithm so for the
algorithm we need to do two things we
need to sort and we also need to count
now let us Implement those steps in this
function right over here calculate
median so here what we can do is we can
take the numbers list
and we can sort it out by using the
inbuilt model of enum so we can say enum
dot sort so now we have a sorted list of
our elements now the second thing is we
need to count if the number of elements
are even or odd and depending on that
scenario we have to handle two different
scenarios so the first scenario was how
to calculate the median when the count
is odd and the second scenario was how
to calculate the median when the length
is even
so for this we would need to create yet
another helper function
so what we can do is we can take the
output of NM dot sort
and let us pipe that output in one more
function by the name of get median now
we don't have this function but we will
create it shortly now this function of
get median is going to receive three
different parameters the first parameter
is obviously the sorted list the second
parameter is going to be a Boolean value
so we will check if the number is odd or
even and the third argument would be the
count itself
so let us pass the argument for this
function now the second argument is
going to be a Boolean value and we can
check if the count is odd or even by
using yet another inbuilt model by the
name of integer so we can call the
inbuilt model of integer and here we can
use the inbuilt function of is even and
let us pass the count
now for calculating the count what we
can do is we can say numbers list and we
can pipe this one into another function
called as enum dot count the next
argument for the function of get median
is going to be the count itself so here
again what we can do is we can say
numbers list and we can pipe the output
into enum dot count now as you can see
we have little bit of repetition so what
we can do is we can take this one out
from here and let me create a variable
called as count
let me put it right over here and we can
simply replace this by the variable of
count
and this also gets replaced by the
variable of count now the last thing to
do is we simply have to define the
function of get median
so let me use the separator right over
here and let me create the function of
get median now this function receives
three parameters the first parameter is
our list of numbers the second parameter
is actually going to be a Boolean value
so let me write in Bool for now and the
third parameter is going to be count now
let us see what we can do with this
function now for this function we again
have two scenarios right so if we go
back to the algorithm
so the first scenario is odd and the
second scenario is even so what we can
do is we can simply use pattern match
right over here so this integer dot even
is going to give us a Boolean in the
terms of true and false so here what we
can do is let us pattern match on false
so that means this list is not even that
means this list is going to be odd and
since this list is going to be odd we
simply have to take the element at the
center and return it back and
fortunately it's very easy again for
this we are going to use the inbuilt
model of enum and there is an inbuilt
function called as at so this function
accepts two different parameters the
first is obviously going to be our list
of numbers
and the second parameter is going to be
the index so for the index what we can
do is we can simply take the count and
we can divide that count by 2.
now there is one small issue over here
so this count divided by 2 this actually
returns back a float and the index value
cannot be flowed so suppose if this
value returns an integer such as 4.5 so
in that case we don't have any values or
rather we don't have any index called as
4.5
so what we need to do is we need to have
an integer Division and not a float
division over here so in order to ensure
that we get back an integer we can use
the inbuilt function of division
so the first argument is going to be the
count and the second argument is going
to be the number now again this function
has to be private so let me put it as
Def and P so this is the first scenario
where the list is odd the second
scenario is what happens when the list
is even
so let me just copy all of this and let
me paste it right over here now for the
second scenario is the list is even so
we get a true right over here
and let us see what we are supposed to
do in this case
so if you go back to the algorithm
so in this case we have to take two
values from the center and then we
simply have to divide them by 2 and
return back the value so let us do
exactly those things right over here
now what we can do is let us create two
variables to hold the values from the
center so we can say that the first
variable is a and let me copy this
function right from here now in this
case we have to take one previous value
right so if I go back over here we want
to take the value which is right over
here
so what we can do is we can say count
minus of 1
and let me again copy and paste for the
next value we don't need minus 1 and let
us call that variable as B
so now we have both the values from the
center and we simply have to add a plus
of B and we just want to divide them by
2. and that's it now as soon as I saved
my file we can see that we are getting a
small error right over here so what is
this saying that you must require
integer before invoking the macro so
what's happening is elixir is actually
using a macro
so macro is a kind of a code that
generates yet another code but for now
we don't have to go into the specifics
we just have to do whatever this error
message is telling us so if you just
refer the message it is saying that we
simply have to require integer so let's
do exactly the same thing so let me go
to the top and here I can say that I
want to require the model of integer
and that's it now the error should be
gone
yes now all of the errors are sorted out
the last thing is let us go to our
public API let us go to lib and under
lip let us go to the model of stacks and
let us create a depth delegate right
over here as well
let us use the macro of Def delegate and
we can say that we want to define the
function of median now this function
accepts the list of our numbers
and we simply want to delegate this
function to the module of median but
before let us create an alias right on
the top so what we can do is we can
import different modules on the same
line
so we can say that I also want to import
median right over here
now here on line number nine we simply
want to delegate the execution to the
model of median so now let me open up my
terminal and let me go inside IEX
and let me clear up everything so here
let us try and invote that function so
we can say stats dot median
and let us create a list right over here
and let me pass the values so as we can
see we are getting the value as 50. now
what I have done is this is a list of
our odd numbers next let me pass one
more list which has even numbers
so let me take out 90 I don't need 90
from here and in this case we are
getting the value as 45. well that's it
for this video and I will catch you
right in the next one
hello and welcome to the last video of
the series so the last video is all
about learning something which is called
as mode
now what exactly is a mode so let me try
and explain but before that what I've
done is behind the scenes I've created
this file mode.ex inside central
tendency and let us see now how we can
find the mode of our elements so what
exactly do we mean by mode
so mode is basically the element which
repeats most often
so for example if we have this array of
values then the mode of this values
would be the values that are repeating
the most now in this example the most
repeating values are 4 and 8 that's why
the mode of this is 4 and 8. now you
must be thinking what is the use of mode
so let me try and help you why mode is
very important now suppose this values
actually stand for the product ID of the
candies which Lewis is selling so for
example one could be the product ID for
the red candies
two could be the product ID for the
yellow one three could be for the green
one so by finding out the mode we can
understand which candies Lewis was able
to sell the most so in this example we
can say that the candy with the idea of
4 and the candy with the idea of 8 where
the most popular and is inside the store
so let us see how we can find out more
so I have given the steps over here so
it's basically a three-step process the
first is we have to find the number of
occurrences or the frequencies next we
have to find the maximum number of
occurrences and finally we have to group
The Elements which have the maximum
occurrences now instead of directly
writing the code this time let me show
you inside the IEX how you can find the
solution for this one
so let me just copy this one and let me
open up my terminal so let me go inside
my IEX and let me clear up the screen
now if we refer to the steps the first
step is we have to find the occurrences
or the frequencies
so let me paste the values right over
here and we can find out the frequencies
by using the inbuilt function so we can
pipe these values
to enum dot frequencies and here it is
so now we have all of the values and
their frequencies as well
so what I would like to do is I would
like to Simply Save this in a variable
called as ranked map
so now we have a ranked map
the next step is we have to find the
maximum number of occurrences
so let us see how we can do that let me
clear up my screen so now we have the
ranked map
for finding out the maximum number of
occurrences what we can do is we can
take the ranked map and from this map
let us simply take the values so we can
say map dot values and let us see how it
looks like
so these are just the values the next is
we simply have to find the maximum value
out of this map
so what we can do is we can type this
one into yet another function called as
enum dot Max
and here it is so the maximum number any
value is repeating is Thrice and if you
refer to our map we can see that 4 is
repeating price and 8 is also repeating
Thrice
now there is a small caveat for finding
out the mode in case the elements are
not repeating more than once in that
case we can't find out the mode but if
we have Elements which are repeating
more than once only in that case we can
find a valid mode
so now let me do one thing let me copy
this one and let me save this into yet
another variable called as Max let me
clear up all of these things so now we
have the ranked map and we also have the
maximum count the next step is we simply
have to filter this react map for the
maximum number of occurrences so in this
case we saw that 4 is repeating Thrice
and 8 is also repeating Thrice so we
simply want to filter it out so let us
see how we can do this so for this what
we can do is we can take the ranked map
and then we can use the function called
as map dot filter now this function
accepts two parameters the first is your
map and the second is your Anonymous
function so let us write a function
right over here now for each iteration
this function is going to receive the
key and also the value pairs from our
map and for each iteration we simply
want to filter out for the values where
the value is equal to our maximum count
so now we have a filtered map the next
step is we simply have to take out the
keys and that's it so let us see how we
can do that so we can take this exact
same expression and then we can say that
we just want to take the keys from our
map and that's it we have our final
answer
so let us go back to the code editor and
let us see how we can do all of these
things right over here
now for this example I am not going to
do all of the validation and error
reporting because I suppose you know how
to do all of those things
so let us directly go inside and see how
to write the functions for our mode
so let me take all of these things up
and here let us Define a function and
here we can say that we want to define a
function called as mode
now this function receives a parameter
which is the list of numbers so I can
simply add a card over here so is list
for my numbers now if you want you can
do all of the extra validation but for
this video I am not going to do the
validation so the first step was finding
the frequencies
so let me create a variable called as
ranked map and here what we can do is we
can simply take the numbers
and let us pipe those numbers to enum
dot frequencies next what we can do is
let us try and find the maximum number
of occurrences
so for that what we can do is we can
take the ranked map we can pipe this
function into map dot value so now we
have all of the values with us next let
us find out the maximum number of
occurrences so we can pipe this into yet
another function
enum dot Max
so now we have the ranked map and we
also have the maximum number of
occurrences now the last thing to do is
we simply have to filter out our ranked
map and for that let us create a helper
function
so here let us pipe this into yet
another helper function by the name of
mode func now this function is going to
accept two parameters the first
parameter would be for the maximum
number of occurrences and the second
parameter would be for the rank map
itself
so let me Define a private function mode
of func now this function accepts two
parameters the first parameter is for
the maximum number of occurrences the
second parameter is for our rank of map
now here we need to take care of one
more condition and that is we can find
more only if the number of occurrences
are more than one so for this function
definition let us have a pattern match
right over here
so we can see that in case the maximum
number of occurrences are 1
in that case we simply have to ignore
the rank map because we can't find out
the mode and let us simply written back
nil but in case we have the occurrences
which are more than one
so to handle that situation let us
Define one more function overload right
over here
so we can say mode of func and the first
parameter was for the maximum value the
second parameter was for our ranked map
so let's take the ranked map and next we
simply have to filter it out so we can
say map dot filter and here let us
Define the anonymous function so we can
say function now for each iteration this
is going to receive the key and also the
value and what we need to do is we
simply want to filter it out when the
value
is equal to our Max and the last thing
is we simply have to take out the keys
from this one so we can say map
dot keys now the last thing to do is let
us go to our stats.ex and let us create
a def delegate right over here so you
can say depth delegate let us create a
function for the mode this also accepts
our numbers list
and we simply want to delegate this to
the model of more but first let us
import it right over here
so we can say we also want to import
more
and this one we simply want to delegate
to more now let me collapse my sidebar
and let me open up my terminal now let
us recompile this one more time and let
me clear up everything so now we can
call stats dot mode and let me pass the
values right over here
and as expected we get back the answer
as 4 and 8. well this brings us to the
end of this course but before I can see
my final words I wanted to show you a
couple of things now if you refer to the
code from my GitHub repository so which
is this one now inside my official
GitHub repository what I have done is I
have implemented two more functionality
which are under the folder of
variability
the first one is about variance the
second one is all about your standard
deviation now I am not going to cover
these parts inside this tutorial series
because I think they are more towards
your mathematical modeling and
statistics while this course was
designed to give you a fair idea about
functional programming in Elixir but I
have kept them for a reference you can
refer them and you can see how I am able
to model variance and standard deviation
for statistics
well that's it from me and I will catch
you in the next one
hi I hope you really had fun learning
functional programming along with me now
this course was designed to teach you
all of the basic constructs of the
functional programming language but
Elixir has a lot more to it the next
things that you would want to learn is
all about the concurrency and the OTP
framework and after you learn the
concurrency framework then you can go
ahead and you can learn the awesome
Phoenix framework as well
now coming back to this course if you
are finding functional programming to be
little difficult it's not your fault it
takes some time patience and practice
before you can understand functional
programming language but after you get
the hang of functional programming
language believe me you would never want
to go back to your object oriented
programming or your imperative
programming Paradigm as well
so let me conclude this course and let
me conclude this video
and do let me know in the comments uh
how would you find this course and you
can also connect with me on my website
it's um octylium.com and also on Twitter
my handle is at the rate of earlier and
if you're feeling generous you can all
you can buy me a coffee it's buy me a
coffee.com slash octallium and also do
let me know if you want to learn some
more Concepts from me if you would like
to learn OTP framework the Phoenix
framework or if you would like to learn
mathematics and statistical modeling
from me or any other topic that you
would like to learn from me as well
so that's it from me and I will catch
you in the next one bye